and we are live yet again with another
speed
chess championship match in this year of
2020.
alongside me grand master young ludwig
hammer back as he should be
as magnus carlson returns for his second
match of the year
hammer magnus returns we've got
vladislav artemyev online and blitz
i don't want to say specialist but a guy
that i think less known than magnus
carlson could give a fight today
your thoughts quickly before we dive
into the format on what magnus needs to
do to make sure he
he maintains and holds off let us love
our chimeyev
um there's no easy match in chess
and magnus is coming straight off a
finals loss
in the champions chess tour so artemyev
i think needs to pounce
on the few times magnus
is vulnerable and and and and strike
while the iron is hot first of all
that's a fantastic point you know before
we dive into
more i want to i want to bring that up
because you said in our last commentary
uh session together with magnus
playing is that magnus is rarely put on
tilt right so
we know the guy's good right he's the
world champion he's the best in the
world
but also he's so good that very often
you know
he he can also win games on momentum his
opponents can be intimidated
you rarely see him put in a position
where he's kind of
having to gather his emotions and in
this particular format of the scc
with so many games back to back you know
what what would that do to put magnus in
that kind of position especially as you
highlighted
he did just lose on his birthday to
wesley so right at the stealing open
uh yeah so i i think uh
crucially you need to try and win two
games in a row against madness
uh because that will really put him in
an
unfamiliar situation the problem of
course
is that winning two games in a row
against magnus is
incredibly difficult right and that's
why he
doesn't have any experience dealing with
with that situation
right okay yeah well said and it's funny
because maybe the last time we
experienced that
before wesley defeating uh magnus at the
skilling open last week was was maybe
back in 2019 when wesley defeated
magnus at the fisher random world chess
championship so you're right it doesn't
happen often
will it happen today or will magnus do
what we expect magnus to do often
which is which is win his chess match
handily either way let's remind the fans
real quick what's coming up here this is
the scc
we gotta we gotta make sure you know
what you're in store for in case you've
missed it
it's a 16 player single elimination
knockout bracket
2020 speed chess championship is the
same format we've had for years it's a
winning format
90 minutes counting down of five minutes
60 minutes of three minute
followed by 30 minutes of bullet of
course the one second increment
throughout
make sure that the chess x's and o's
always matter just as much if not more
than what's on the clock if a match is
tied hammer we will head to overtime
we've had one match go to overtime
uh this year for ruja fedo say which the
fans who've been here early you just had
the pleasure of seeing in our
highlight clips of the month you can
check out that video on youtube
hammer we've also got double the prizes
here in round two
so it's 3k to the winner and then 3k
split on win percentage
your your thoughts real quick on why
more events don't do
prizes distributed based on win
percentage
um didn't expect i don't really know
it's a really good question i was
actually trying to do some calculations
whether or not a tournament like norway
chess
um can can can try to award
uh wins monetarily and how that would
look
as a structure um and i i think it's uh
the concept is great and then
you need to figure out how to execute it
right and well i think you guys have
some experience with that
right yeah it's in we talk about it a
lot and of course it you know i'm the
guy who's been doing chess.com shows
since since they started so
i guess no way it doesn't sound biased
coming out of my mouth but you know i've
talked about this just as friends and
chess professionals off camera and i
you know we're always talking about ways
to make sure chess maintains its
fighting spirit even down the stretch
right
we've talked about ways that you know
they do scoring uh different we know uh
norway
chess has tried that and and find ways
to reward you know
points with black and with white and
make sure that chess is fighting and and
we always look at this as an opportunity
to make sure that even if a match is a
runaway
there's still something to fight for and
now within maybe the several hundreds of
dollars for each individual game so
anyway fun stuff and either way several
hundred dollars is also on the line
this week with multiple scc matches for
guests to move
if you want to play head over to
chess.com click on that button
below the chess tv player you'll be
taken directly to live chest to follow
the games
or one of our very helpful and awesome
moderators and staff can share a link
with you
on youtube and twitch leaving those
boring platforms behind you know what
you can't do
on twitch and youtube play chess that's
dumb
go to chess.com and play chess anyway
the bracket
hammer so has moved on to the semifinals
maxine bache the grave has moved on to
the semifinals we've got two matchups
coming up
and honestly i just want to move right
into our predictions here because it's
it's not quite what we had
magnus carlsen as the favorite over mock
sudo the last time we were here
but still pretty heavily in magnus's
favor right
i mean whenever magnus plays chess he's
gonna be
the favorite uh and muksudulu i wanna
give credit to him that
he got a lot of good positions he had
a lot of uh good opportunities he just
let them slip when both players were
down to
25 20 seconds each uh artemyev
if he wants to get a good showing he
needs to do
what magsudu did but he also needs to
strike
in those time critical situations
and uh being low on time the lower time
the more randomness the easier it is to
make a blunder
you want to put yourself in that
situation
where the game is competitive with uh 20
seconds remaining
and maksudulu did that but then failed
in the critical situations
um artemyev needs to do the same and
then
succeed uh as the the time
becomes stressful very well said and
obviously maybe not everyone here who's
uh who's here early
remembers the monsoon mesh closely but
uh but you and i do and and i think you
make a great point there it's easy
to look at the scoreboard right hammer
when it's over and say oh magnus won by
a lot but actually
a lot of those games as it is with super
grand masters we're still very close
down the stretch so will vladislav
artemyev
succeed where mog sulu failed and as you
said maybe the recipe
to upsetting uh you know a goliath like
magnus carlsen
is not just once but twice in a row
right put him in a position where you're
you're building momentum see if he can
recover from the the tilt factor that is
in the scc
that so many people have experienced um
and
and then hope for the best right well we
have about 60 seconds before the game
starts so give a quick shout out
the chess tv the twitch to youtube we
still got
actually got a lot of you here pretty
early just because magnus is playing
this morning a little bit of a different
time zone than we've normally done these
sccs
and the first time we've had a back to
back in a uh
in a in a very what a day it's gonna be
what a day right what a day it's gonna
be um i joked i woke up early this
morning it was like hey
this is tiring and then i was like what
am i talking about i get to go
commentate
with magnus and ikaro and hammer this is
gonna be an awesome day and i can't wait
um and uh and yeah i think games will be
beginning
in just seconds here it's time it's time
to begin let's do this thing
what do you think you ready um i'm ready
uh and i hope the players are ready as
well because here it's gonna be
important
to uh to get a good start and and take
take advantage of the white pieces
whomever is so lucky
to benefit from those well by the way um
before the game
starts we just had a subscriber which
reminds me i get to give an early shout
out
to all those who are here to throw us
your throw us your prime hence the
reason we named him primetime smackdown
right
subtle suggestive marketing there
because guess who plays during our
primetime smackdown today hammer
uh or are you going to show our prime
time smackdown daniel that's right
the one where i crushed looking forward
to it destroyed you
that one no spoilers danny no spoilers
okay uh it's gonna be awesome i can't
wait
so if you are not a subscriber to twitch
um we do we do appreciate it we know
that uh we obviously run ads it's no
secret here
this content we bring you a lot goes
into our events here at chess.com and we
appreciate you
you uh putting up with that as we as we
try to bring you the best content and
chef shows
uh online in the world as best we can
anyway and if you do want to avoid ads
please consider throwing us a
subscription
you can also watch on chess.comtv for an
ad free experience
um and uh we do appreciate your premium
membership over there as well so
um anyway thank you so much for everyone
who's already here
and uh please consider consider watching
me and hammer at the primetime smackdown
let's just say that
no matter what happens between us i
always have fond memories
uh thank you danny um okay
um we are
going to say something funny no that
wasn't funny enough
hamster 0730 just no i don't like that
guy
i i was going to try and say something
funny but i failed in the moment and i
tried to relay the word to you instead
your trash talk has been wittier than i
expected um
at times i'm not gonna lie um so
don't be gentle today be gentle you know
i i've i've been
i've been coached by the best hey
it's not you i'm not i was waiting for
the punch line there you go
[Music]
okay no i think botas is a fantastic
trash talker oh my god don't even i i
don't even know
um anyway well we're waiting for the
games to begin thank you seriously
the uh the subscribers coming in we do
appreciate it it's gonna be a great day
and
uh no more ads as you subscribe um i
think the players are ready but
obviously there's something going on and
just so everyone knows the players are
discussing with our team
there's a lot of staff that goes into
making these things possible
and both players are also on double
camera which means fair play review
so they have a field of vision camera a
front-facing camera and then also on
screen share
um and so really doing everything we can
to make sure that
uh that both the players feel secure
that their opponents are
are properly observed and proctored and
the um
and the audience can know that even
though these days there are all kinds of
earpieces and things people do and
everyone knows that chess.com
algorithm for cheat detection is mostly
based on dna evidence of the game right
data that kind of removes the question
of what people might be doing
just want you to know we're doing that
hammer have you ever played a tournament
where you had
multiple cameras on you a chess
tournament by the way not that other
kind of tournament
uh i the only place would be somewhere
like norway chess
which was tv broadcasted oh okay but
other than that no okay well
we'll go to full we'll go to the larger
camp for us as the players get set
they're working out some technical
difficulties at the moment
um players are allowed to listen to
music but not through headphones which
again
confirms all different sound waves they
might be hearing
always possible someone's watching this
show they see a brilliant suggestion by
danny wrench
and then someone tells them in the ear
magnus danny just said to play this move
play it that's that's a real life
scenario
i like how you could have used me as an
example but chose to go with yourself
i'm just being realistic buddy just be
your confidence is
incredible um everyone should aspire to
have your confidence
i you know i appreciate that um you know
the other thing people can aspire to do
is
play in tomorrow's bot battles hammer we
know that you're
you're super busy um for those who don't
know you are literally the face of tv2
and in some ways just commentary in
norway i would argue
um but uh you're also an aspiring chess
streamer you have a you have a twitch
channel maybe one of our mods can uh can
throw a thorough command in there for
people to go give hammer a follow
i don't know if you'll be streaming
tomorrow but the bot battles are gonna
be a ton of fun
i'm pretty sure everybody is playing all
the cool kids are playing i'm going to
play
meaning i'm not even going to do
commentary i'm going to play and try to
win some of the bounty prizes i'm
certainly going to beat the living tar
out of young beth harmon i'll tell you
that
that sounded weird so who's this guy on
the left
what who's this guy on the left is it i
know it looks like a uh
a young and somehow creepier john
travolta
if that's even is that who you compare
yourself to john travolta
no it just it looks like a creepy john
travolta you know all the movies he has
slicked back terror
it's not a compliment it's it's it's
awkward i i gotta talk to uh
to dallyn um our our head designer be
like man i would have
rather looked like jimmy neutron than
that
yeah i think in these within these four
there's three very good representations
of the people and then there's
just this plain old white guy
um i i got feedback that i wasn't funny
enough last time and i've
really you are first of all anybody who
says that is wrong
i actually think we have a great a great
rapport
and um i'm i'm uh honored to be your
wingman whenever we have the opportunity
so and
uh i thought i was your wingman no dude
i'm your wingman i'm the wingman of
anyone we bring on here
okay um but uh
oh okay so we're having we're having uh
we're working out some technical stuff
right now with with the zoom screen
share and those sorts of things so
um everyone just uh just hold tight hold
tight don't don't be frustrated
um why don't we bring back are you
talking to yourself right now
yeah talking to myself sometimes i do
that on air in front of also do it at
home in front of my kids i also do it
alone in the shower i do i talk about
myself a lot to myself
um so let's get more specific right we
were we were moving through the preview
content a little faster anticipating a
start time but as we work out the tech
difficulties
um we said that artemiev needs to win a
couple games in a
row to put magnus in that in that
potentially tiltable position
as you look at the time control and our
predictions hammer
where do you where do you feel i mean we
always say the underdog needs to strike
early
right i tend to agree with that um but
where do you feel
uh artemyev needs to get his points
um other than his six and a half to
three score on the five-minute portion
which actually doesn't make any sense i
don't know i'll talk to you it doesn't
but don't be frustrated danny
don't don't don't be frustrated okay
it's all gonna be okay
okay anyway so where do you feel
with your you know self-talk
where do you think artemium needs to
score um
all categories um yeah well the thing is
uh in this format uh the one minute
section has a tendency to just pile on
with a lot of games in a very short time
frame
and and that means if you start losing
two games in a row
in the one minute section then you're
just
done for but what i have noticed
previously in this format is that
matches need to be competitive get going
into the one minute in order for there
to be any drama
very often there's one player who has
shown their superiority
in the blitz sections and by the time we
get
to the bullet section to the one minute
section
then it's just one guy who's been
crushed and whose confidence has been
eviscerated
um and then he stands no chance
to uh to mount a comeback so i think
number one artemium needs to make sure
that there's not more than three points
separating them
going into the one minute section and
then
uh he needs to kind of even if he's down
on points uh he needs to make sure he
still
has the the inner strength the
confidence
that uh he feels he can strike back
uh in the in the bullet section
well said and well timed because right
as you finish that point we do have
liftoff everybody we appreciate you uh
sitting through that um and again just
so you know uh what was going on was
screen share difficulties but uh
regardless of the match and who we have
who we have playing we want to make sure
that
there are no screen share difficulties
and that everyone
is uh being observed in the same way so
we didn't want to start early to make
before all security measures were uh
were taken
and uh we have magnus carlsen playing
the modern variation if you know your
move orders in the caro con and queen to
c7
that's a that's not an everyday move
there from our champion
big surprise from artemyev and i like
his opening choice
he's using the karo khan against magnus
who used the korokan against wesley's
soul just
last week and lost
with it using the black pieces artemiev
is essentially
uh bringing up some bad memories here
from
bringing lots of bad memories for magnus
magnus
took some took a minute there before he
played bishop d3
um but uh but now we're headed toward
what is sort of a typical
kind of call it classical french
structure with the with the exchange of
the d for the e
pawn but with this these on c6 and queen
on c7 thrown in what
what what does that do to change the
dynamic does black have an early e5 in
his future
i don't know it looks kind of strange
from artemyev
but at least he got magnus to spend some
time
in the opening this is very reminiscent
of uh
games i've seen with uh the big anatoly
karpov
the the master of the carbocon opening
uh
and um it's so solid it's very difficult
to
break down and and magnus is going to
have a tough time with it today
okay interesting and he is also down on
the clock which maybe not exactly what
we
uh what we expected for the start of the
match um
well you know well magnus is a slow
starter that's true
remember he mouse slipped in game one
last time
and and in his match against
uh magsodulu the score was two to two
when magnus won 10 games in a row
and managing to win 10 in a row is
incredible
but it goes to show that we thought
maxoudaly was doing a great job
initially
and then he just got crushed right so
you can never rest easy playing against
magnus
right now great point although you also
made the point as i was asking you to
break down the time controls that
regardless of the score
artemia needs to keep the inner
confidence he needs to keep the inner
focus right and i will say that
one thing i've observed about vladislav
one of the most consistent performers i
think outside of hikaru nakamura in our
speeches grand prix this year
uh hammer is he is kind of that he's got
that emotionless killer kind of mindset
you know he doesn't
doesn't seem to get rattled every time i
would say you know oh that's a huge
blunder you think he's going to lose his
focus
he does have that which i think is kind
of uh something that a lot of the top
players have right where they sort of
have a short memory
about mistakes right and so we'll see if
he can he can maintain himself
um even if the score gets a little bit
rough there um yeah but one of the most
exciting things about these
internet chess tournaments is that the
two best players
magnus and hikaru are also the two
players
most prone to showing their emotions
on camera really
visibly being upset or happy
and so on and so forth and i i think
this has been
one of the greatest things of internet
chess
right that the players because they feel
like they're alone
in their homes uh they're not hiding
their emotions
over the board they would always quell
any sort of
sign the opponent could use whereas here
uh they they show more emotion and
frankly that's fantastic
and i love that magnus and ikaru the two
best players
are the most visible in in in relaying
uh what's going on in their head again
well said we've talked about that a lot
with the scc and then other events like
the pro chess league and
other things that there's been in some
ways a more intimate connection fans
have felt online with players because of
exactly what you said you get you get
this sort of view
of and the immediate reaction because
players are so comfortable right you
know when you're not wearing pants
it's easier to let your guard down you
know just are you wearing pants danny
that may or may or may not it's business
up top party down low the chest
commentators world
and look at this from magnus magnus had
the opportunity to castle
but he was scared that the kings would
be on opposite sides of the board
allowing artemyev to start an attack
and so magnus by bringing his bishop out
he's signaling
that he's kind of scared and that he
wants to put his king
on the same side as artemis king because
that's
known as being a safer positioning
100 and i wonder if it changes the end
game slightly right so when we look at
the long term nature of the four on
three but then the three on two on this
side
but black's king is already on that side
of the board that typically is a good
spot if you get to an end game and
you're dealing with someone trying to
convert a passer
so that's i mean a lot of things about
this position to me are just not clear
yet right there's there's
and that's probably why the engine also
feels it's a very very close to level
position
but then i look at the clock after that
whole kind of tangent and say
artemia doing well with black right he's
uh yeah
i was gonna say uh a big uh
one minute advantage on the clock for
the russian
and here he goes striking out against
white's queen as well
very aggressive play from him magnus is
going to be trying to show
that uh in in the words of our coach
seaman augustine magnus will try to show
that bishops are best in the long games
that they stay alive for a long time uh
get into an end game where there are
fewer pawns
and bishops are best the fewer the pawns
on the board
because both your own pawns and uh
your opponent's pawns have a tendency of
getting in the way of bishops
and and so that's why they're good uh in
the long run
as the pawns get exchanged off
so we have uh siemen augustine to thank
for your great series on chess.com on
the bishop pair and you're in magnus's
brilliant
play i already knew that but i'm
pretending pretending i didn't anyway
no great point in all this highlight
again the bishop here is sort of white's
long-term trump card here because of the
the fact that black doesn't have a light
square bishop so right now it's not
you know not not necessarily an issue
but that's what
magnus is hoping for in the long run
okay we're starting to get spicy here
hammer knight b6 opens the rook
will will our chimney of risk going for
this pawn i highly doubt that yeah he
says no
no thank you i'll make the king safe
and magnus still down one minute on the
clock and he's about to be
under one minute in total which is a
huge
time advantage for artemyev and he's
going to be looking to keep
pieces on the board to keep the
situation
difficult and and try to get magnus
in with a bad decision in time trouble
bishop to c1 to renew defense on the
night
um i think hammer highlighted the
biggest the biggest point here which is
time
but i still like magnus's position in
the long run regardless of what the
computer says i feel like the bishop
pair
will have the potential to strike um
what is what is black i agree yeah i
agree there's
nothing wrong with magnus's position
it's just the time
is precarious and i think the biggest
mistake artemia can do
make now is is just sit there and run
his clock trying to find the best move
sometimes you need to be a little
cynical
and say well i'm not going to play
perfect chess
but it doesn't matter because by playing
quickly
i can put a lot of pressure on my
opponent who's maybe
not very used to being in a situation
where he's
low on time and and prone to making
mistakes so i think
artemyev spending a half a minute on one
move there
was um unnecessary
no well said and now now he goes for
this plan a bishop d6 trying to trying
to take advantage of the queen
being in a precarious spot it's actually
kind of awkward
yeah magnus's queen has been kicked
around a lot this game
and it's clear that he's settling into
the match
because he's still spending so much time
while the p
sacrifice from magnus giving away a
piece for two pawns
he's about to get a third pawn on g4 but
in general a piece is very valuable
and artemia also doing a good job of
getting rid of magnus's bishop pair
he has the upper hand both on the board
and
on the clock it's it's super interesting
magnus went for that
i guess from a practical point of view
he was feeling both the pressure of his
queen
and the fact that he's getting low on
the clock but yeah i i like that
artillery if not that he took the piece
hammer but that he did so very quickly
he's like all right here we go
i'm not going to overthink this let's go
keep magnus under time pressure
um i think but with
three pawns for the for the
for the bishop uh i think it's very
important that artemyev keep
hold on to his pawn on age six
uh because if magnus is able to
eliminate
all the pawns on one side of the board
his defensive task on the other side
becomes
much easier so that might may explain
why artemiev chose to use the rook that
was in the center of the board
and used that one to push over to the
side because he wants to keep his corner
rook protecting that
very important remaining pawn a great
point what do you think about
magnus's queen trade there right he's
relying on the end game where
in some ways the knights are not always
the best pieces coordinating
against maybe ideas where the you know
you start doing things on the king side
here it's interesting
yeah i don't think magnus has given up
hope on winning this game
right um and now he also equalized on
time
we're gonna get one of those dramatic 20
seconds each
situations and this could go either way
i'm surprised how positive the computer
is
for black precisely for the reason you
mentioned
that the knights are difficult to
coordinate but here come the knights
artemia maneuvering them over to the
center pushing around
magnus's bishop uh ma artemia in a good
situation
but both players so low on time it's
anyone's game
100 agree and yeah the coordination
you'd like it but again the more i look
at it i feel like white's doing
maybe better than the computer says too
but okay this is it's gonna be a photo
finish regardless
yeah and look at how artemia is putting
the pressure down on that white pawn
artemyev gets the pawn captured magnus
is relying on getting that
last pawn on the other side but artemia
with his rook is trying his best to
prevent it
but he fails magnus gets the pawn on the
age file
which means magnus now only has to
concentrate
on defending uh the left-hand side of
the board
and yeah i i think he has decent chances
to you know
get out of time with the drug tim did
get the second rank right which gets you
worried about future mating nets even
with the rook and knight
a little bit right a little bit uh
and magnus also down to less than 10
seconds
as is our tamiya it's gonna be one heck
of a finish
but there magnus blunders his pawn on
the side
uh artemia doesn't pick it up
pawn is alive but the other side of the
board is not alive
artemia with a great job there uh
getting
magnus on the side where he thought he
was comfortable and artemyev
is gonna take the win in this uh first
game uh
showing everyone that he is not going
down without a fight
yeah and by the way wins with black
right
um i mean assuming he converts here um
he will convert this i have no doubt
yeah i don't know that the psac was was
really dubious by magnus i mean from a
practical perspective i think it was
super interesting
it's just that artemiev played quickly
handled it well
and uh and ultimately an extra piece
proved better in the time scramble
again our champion look at the technique
protects the knight now the rook will
come back to f2
and uh and magnus just throws in the
towel so
wow right we have liftoff everybody if
you if you showed up this morning
early on the west coast or mid-afternoon
over there somewhere in europe
thinking all right time for another
magnus steamroll as as robner and i
predicted yesterday i don't think either
one of these back-to-back matches are
going to be easy for the favorites
magnus or hikaru so
stick around and that that first game
proves it
hammer you said artemium needs to win
two in a row to put magnus in in a
position
now he has the white pieces and a chance
to do it early
yeah and if he succeeds what a success
for him
but on the other hand magnus is infamous
for striking back with a win after a
loss
and here he goes again being aggressive
with the pawn on the side of the board
um i
i think magnus is slightly worse
with the black pieces uh but winning
this for artemyev and really unsettling
magnus is
is gonna be uh really difficult and
magnus can live with being uh one game
down
because there's three hours to left
right that's true but all right our team
of
doing early what what mag zulu failed to
do for
for a very long time in in their first
matchup which was get a w
make sure magnus knows uh this is not
gonna be a walk in the park
we got 10 000 of you on twitch 4 000
plus of you on youtube and the day has
just begun
appreciate all the love we've been
getting lots of subscribers lots of chat
rolling on chess tv too and uh
and thank you for being here um all
right
uh james coleman says black gonna win
this right because or maybe that was
from the previous game i don't know
but uh all right what is what does
magnus need to do here hammer what's the
plan in this kind of obscure looking
weird ready g3 stuff
look at magnus's pawns danny do you see
anything
they have in common uh
well a lot of them are on light squares
if i'm looking at the queen side i also
see a natural idea of going for e5
um well i have the suspicion that magnus
is going to place
every single pawn on a light square
which
doesn't really work well together with a
light squared bishop
so magnus coming forward with his knight
in the center
he's going to be hope that artemyev
captures the knight in the center
so that magnus can take back with his
bishop
and i think it's likely we'll see magnus
giving up
the knight squared bishop for a night
essentially
saying uh that um
that the bishop uh can get a um
can't really do anything uh so it's
better to get it exchanged off
uh given how many pawns are still on the
board
yeah and he does so uh quick uh quick
trigger happy board resize for those who
are gonna clip that and make fun of me
later
we'll work on that little mouse
sensitivity anyway um all right he gets
the bishop in
so i was gonna highlight if you said
he's gonna put all his pawns on light
squares then the idea of getting the
bishop outside the pawn chain
makes a lot of positional sense but here
comes artemia forcing the issue on the
queen side right
he wants tension to break wants things
like a capture to open up the a file
here
um again again i kind of like how our
timmy is playing yeah mainly he's
looking at
magnus's pawn on b7 and that's the
the guy you always want to get after uh
when your opponent
uh lets the bishop out of its cage
um right and
i'm not sure how magnus should defend
that guy it's a difficult thing
because probably he wants to use his
queen
but if he moves his queen to d7 he's got
to count on what happens if if white
moves the knight up
uh in the center uh if the queen goes to
c8 or
c7 he's putting the queen on the same
file
as white's rook which is
not a good thing to have happen to the
so magnus right now struggling to find
out
how to defend the pawn wait
i'm surprised yeah i'm surprised by that
decision from magnus
because now now we have an opening on
on the on the far side and it feels to
me like
white is better prepared uh to get
something out of that
well you said it too the queen can't
guard the b-pawn at least not
safely on the c file um
queen d7 does it but
are we worried about ideas with the
knight coming in are we
no i don't think so i think uh
we're happy to give up our bishop for
that night should it get into the center
but magnus was not happy with that but
his decisions have cost so much time
magnus once again down on time
over a minute and he puts his queen on
that same file as white's rook
which is something you mostly want to
avoid
and here we see artemyev trying to take
advantage
of uh the opening on on the side rank
trying to get the work involved uh all
the way down on the other side
are we going to see knight a6 or knight
d7 right it feels like rook a8 is too
powerful a threat
for a magnus oh wait a second holy
begins
not see that one coming yep that's a pin
i like it yeah what what tension
between the pawns all four pawns looking
at each other
and frankly none of them wants to
capture
uh but you're gonna have to uh it's uh
live or die for those pawns over the
next couple of moves
yeah i wonder if magnus has a way to
force white um let's bring up the
analysis board and just
quickly show the the obvious right the
whole point is hammer said you can't
take here because of that oh well hammer
magnus does capture c4 but the risk i
thought was
but if queen takes maybe maybe magnus
will take twice actually right trying to
strap an end game where maybe white ends
up with an isolated pawn as a weakness
on d4 as is maybe in the future
yeah so uh vladislav takes with the pawn
instead
trying to build good central control
with his pawns now magnus he's going to
try to claim that those pawns are
vulnerable but on the other hand taking
with the pawn has now
allowed for the the white queen to give
protection to the fianchetto
bishop which is very good for white
because that means you can continue
pushing forward
in the middle if it was artemium's move
right now he would play
d5 and magnus is down two minutes
on the clock which means he is not at
all comfortable with what is going on
here
yeah and and if you just tuned in this
was a similar story from game one
uh magnus was was way down on the clock
ultimately it did come down to a very
equal time scramble but still
it shows that our champion is capable
out of the first stage of things of
making magnus uncomfortable
um big moment now artemium has 95
big tactics going on and magnus shaking
his head
magnus sees what's going on we have to
do that on the analysis
so the idea everyone is if 95 bishop
takes takes e4
you can't take because the rook hangs so
95 is a monster move black would have to
take on b5 first
and then what happens here right hammer
it's a total mess
yeah i don't really know but black's
knight
did not like this situation however
a different move was played by artemyev
instead he he chose to get his work
involved
immediately and magnus just moving that
rook into a defensive position
but maybe that's what the position
required well maybe magnus was actually
shaking his head kind of to his own time
management like
i i had that thought when he first did
it it wasn't about queen c6 and
he is he is still equal but but only 20
seconds is like hey
there's a lot of chess to be played here
man you got to speed up
yeah and magnus going into an end game
basically just
trying to defend um
but on the other hand magnus and end
games it's like norwegians and brown
cheese it just goes together what i mean
appropriate would have been salmon
norwegians and salmon brown cheese
it's good i promise it's
well you learn something new every day
here on chess tv at least
at least you can go home and say that um
what you need to know danny
is that we sell the salmon
you know ah you you you i
think norway is is all about salmon but
we sell it
we let other people i was there last
year and just about every buffet i went
to you know scandinavians and how much
they love their buffets
every single buffet breakfast lunch and
dinner had salmon
okay back to the game okay magnus is
unwinding with b6 hammer
knight d6 coming next and uh something
tells me like you said
magnus and and end games norwegians and
brown cheese i think magnus is gonna do
okay down the stretch here
yeah even with just 20 seconds remaining
magnus is the one going for the win in
an
end game and that's because white has
two pawns
that are disconnected from the rest of
the army
these two pawns are unable uh to be
defended by
other pawns meaning they need pieces
in defensive positions and as magnus now
is coming with his knight uh to attack
the
the furthest forward of these pawns
um artemium is gonna have to get his
rook in a defensive position which
is terrible it's just suffering and he
knows it because his time advantage has
gone from 2 minutes to 30 seconds
artemium has completely blown this game
and he knows it the trend now in
magnus's favor
magnus down on the score uh magnus
definitely
going to go for the win here uh even
though he was in a
a precarious time situation earlier
agreed with everything you said i like
the technique there too he's not worried
about the b6 plane i think because
why is he not worried about that pawn i
think he has nice c8
okay but then 20 seconds left hammer
this knight
this knight might might actually fall
prey to some tempe and this this king is
activating itself very quickly up the
board i'm
i don't know i i don't want to jinx
things early but i feel like we might
have a tied match after this given how
magnus is
so so accurate in these types of end
games our tamiya should probably go like
age four and king f3 get that king
involved
towards the middle right but he's
spending
so much time now and he had that big
two-minute time advantage which has
completely disappeared
and that is just not good time
management
he played bad moves and took his time
making them
and now magnus by rook c8 and artemyev
shakes his head
pins the knight knight to see set okay
no reason to play knight c7 it would
just be a trade everybody but
this heads-up retreat of the rook is
just paralyzing for artemyev
yeah magnus is just going to push his
pawn and
that is going to distract white's rook
from the defense of the white knight
and our tamiya loses despite
having a good position despite being two
minutes
up on the clock magnus strikes back
and let's go to the announcement show to
just show that that final moment hammer
because it's kind of fascinating
when a position is equal besides a pawn
on material hammer but look at the eval
plus seven for black
like if you look at the paralyzed nature
of this everyone i just want to point
out how unique it is
the rook cuts off the king and so
there's literally nothing this king can
do
about baby girl brittany joining the
party on b1 the only thing that white
will eventually do
is have to move i mean you sit and
eventually the rook goes well i can't do
this anymore i come back which just
loses the knight
so literally everything in the position
is frozen because of this sort of
uh brilliant and played very quickly
move rook c8 and the game was over the
moment it came on the board
with rook a8 rook c8 so anyway very very
nice technique we are now level as
hammer says we joined
we joined game three and well we've
already got
already got some trickiness with e5 let
me just show the opening real quick
it was another carol khan this time a
classical variation
e5 a pawn sack that is regained quickly
with a common tactic
between 85 check we'll pick up the pawn
here everybody so
your thoughts here hammer this is uh
tibiakov's pet line with the white
pieces
and tibi is one of the players known
to be incredibly difficult to beat his
wide openings are
so solid but magnus uh he's going for
this because he
appreciates the bishop pair so magnus
with
two bishops are temiev with just one
magnus is going to hope for a long game
where his uh bishops can reign supreme
our boy our boy seaman angelstein
strikes again right his influence on you
guys and the bishop here
i'm to go into twitch chat and use one
of my emotes
my boy magnus i'll let you do it
well you'll do that i'll remind
everybody thank you for all the subs
coming in and all the all the chat we're
getting
every room is lively and poppin youtube
twitch chess tv
it's gonna be a fun day the match is
level we've got a bishop pair here and a
carrot con
for the second time when our timmy was
black if you're just tuning in this was
also game one
where vladislav won with the second move
so we'll see if this carro con is a
is a consistent feature here by the way
we had almost a thousand observers
directly in chess.com and a couple
hundred people playing guess the move so
a lot of people playing guess the move
head over to chess.com
if our mods can share a link there and
to play against the move to win cash
prizes
try to play like magnus all right go
ahead hammer
i'm no longer a fan of magnus's bishops
or
to say i'm a fan of the bishops
but i'm not a fan of the knight on g3
and artemyev has just played an
excellent move
restricting this knight's movement uh
taking away that central square in the
middle
um and magnus when he's moving his
bishop now
he's exposing his bishop oh
i thought bishop f3 was played no no
sorry that was a mouse slipped by me on
the board sometimes i get a little
trigger happy i get so excited
yeah because i was gonna say moving the
bishop is definitely
something magnus is considering because
then the knight
can move where the bishop was right
uh it's just that moving the bishop will
allow for artemyev to move
both his knights into uh central
locations
and that's not going to be a fun time
for magnus so i'm going to say the
kurokon
will not be featured a lot in this match
because magnus has gotten a beating with
the white pieces
he's going to have to change his first
move
that's i mean that would be something
right if our champions carol khan
makes magnus change as early as game
five which will be the next time
the norwegian has the white pieces okay
he finds bishop g5 i
i like that move because one of the
things about
the knight coming to the center is the
rook will reinforce protection here
this kind of makes the rook go to an
awkward square and i had a tactic idea
bishop c4 hammer because i'm just the
only potential problem with these pawns
is the light squares right which is the
bishop artemia lacks
doesn't have to move and artemia
with his bishop intercepting uh he's
gotten
rid of magnus's bishop pair yep classic
and magnus
yeah and magnus is still stuck with that
knight
uh um on the edge of the board not
really doing much
but here he goes for the idea i was
talking about and you know i agree with
everything you're saying maybe there's
some tempe
idea magnus can bring the bishop in
bring a rook over but then h2 is weak no
you're right i mean this is super
super awkward for black to the point
where maybe magnus just needs to back up
the bishop and be defensive
and what a move from artemyev there
taking with the king
who would do that and who would do that
at such a pace
he realizes that the rook is no better
in the middle
uh it's actually doing just fine where
it is
pointing towards magnus's pawn on the
side of the board
what a move from artemyev and magnus
once again
shaking his head magnus has been in
trouble
in three games in a row now and for the
third time in a row magnus is
more than a minute down on the clock uh
he made a
good escape in game two and even came
back to win it
but it's very clear to me that artemium
has been the top player
in this match so far he just needs to
you know play better in the crunch
moments
such as that uh second game no i mean
you're right again for those just tuning
in
our champion was was much better as
white even though he lost that second
game for
magnus to tie it um i like this move h3
right you're just fixing the fundamental
problem you'd like to play a move like
rook d1
even bishop f1 if you have to guard g2
to knighto4
magnus is going to slowly kind of unwind
um
the position so i like this idea look at
that hammer he's coming to f6
very solidly placed in the center yeah
and seeing as how
magnus now um
fix the problem on the edge i thought
artemyev was going to bring
now his rook into the center instead
he's trying to exploit the fact
that he has that rook on the side of the
board
putting pressure on magnus's rook pawn
but in those trades that happened
uh magnus was able to get his bad knight
into a good situation in the center
i was highlighting that as soon as f4
was played and my face said at all i was
like huh
what's interesting is as ugly as that
transition looks for these ducklings
here on f3 and f2
black has the same problem uh so so the
position has become very level
um considering artemia's previous
pressure
uh i don't know that a draw is a bad
result for him anyway he's still been
doing very well with the black pieces
but
um something maybe slipped there for for
for artemia
and we've seen that in end games magnus
can be
terrifying even when he's massively down
on the clock
and now he's using his his knight to
terrorize
black's king going after that pawn on g7
but on the other hand our temiev also
has a pawn in his
sights on f3 so um
it might just peter out here uh with i
wonder if
magnus will play a move like night g5
hammer to kick the rook and
maybe open up ideas that the rook gets
involved obviously it's
maybe no better than just a trade of g7
for f3 but
timmy has got to think about that
because i'm wondering about this little
like yeah i like it because my i had
this idea in mind if rook h2 you're not
actually threatening to take because of
this
maybe there's you know look at magnus
yeah he's doing doing his thing
but it was an unfortunate spot for
black's king
uh because magnus had the opportunity
and he didn't take it
to play rook e6 with an attack on
black's king
and an attack on black's pawn and i'm
very surprised magnus didn't go for that
because that's just that's a pawn and
not only is it capturing a pawn it's
also putting pressure on the second
black pawn
i'm surprised magnus didn't go for that
instead yeah that too
uh honestly that's that's like
just a blunder by magnus because i'm
realizing artemia has to go back to the
seventh rank and allow the two pawns
with check everyone because if king c5
you take
you're not even threatening to take that
shake and bake on e4
so this is a this is a uh
i think your right hammer i think not
playing rookie six was
just straight up a blunder by magnus
although
looks like he was kind of happy with
this technical transition he's like well
now i'm in a position with a better
knight i've got pressure on the pawns
but for sure he missed rookie six
and once again we see magnus being way
down on time
but as we enter the end game uh a face
without queens on the board
magnus just reigns supreme and artemyev
can be very happy with his openings but
he needs to start playing these end
games better
uh because uh magnus is uh
is gaining traction even though
he's he's been so far down on time
for three games in a row yeah
i i agree although like you said end
games and brown cheese right
the magnus loves them both um
so gonna be hard for our jimmy maybe to
compete in the most technical
aspect of the game which i think it's
funny people at i think beginner levels
forget that that the end game is really
you know in many ways the hardest most
accurately most demanding phase and
that's one of the reasons magnus
shines so well in it um i think our
teammate is defending
i do believe magnus is gonna regret
having not played rookie six because
i feel like now that this setup is
established
this knight so well kind of defending
everything he'll probably just go back
to c8 here
i don't think artemis loses this oh look
at is that is that vlad saying hey maybe
maybe maybe i'll play this on a little
bit yeah
wow uh a spell of confidence there from
artemyev and now with this check he's
forcing magnus's king back
after which uh artemyev will capture a
pawn
with a check it's a pawn up for artemyev
and it's a great display from him
showing that
he's not afraid of magnus magnus was
inviting this back and forth back and
forth going for the draw
seeing as how he was down on time but
artemyev has understood
that he needs to use his time advantage
more
and he took this opportunity to
to put some pressure on on magnus
ooh but now we're still getting it back
and forth
so magnus obviously a great defender
but it's a a promising sign from
artemyev
that that he was willing uh to go for
the win there
and put pressure on magnus because if
you're gonna play a three-hour
match against the best player in the
world
you're gonna lose if you don't put
pressure on him
you need to put him in those uh tricky
situations
and that whenever magnus is down to 20
seconds
that's a tricky situation and artemia
tried to
uh capitalize on it it didn't work this
time
but maybe next time uh he he may reap
the rewards but let's let's bring up the
analysis board and just show that point
because it's going to be a storyline
throughout the day you're 100
right that right here when there was an
opportunity for a potential repeating of
moves everyone
the second time it came our timing said
you know what i'll play king b6
and now you're in a bit of a tricky
situation with rook four not just the
ideas i said of advancing but
f3 falling so it ultimately did end in a
draw
but it's hammer's point is that you
can't play passive and and be happy for
a draw against magnus he makes magnus
accept the perpetual here rather than
the other way around so again
just a good psychological point there
made from hammer we'll see if that
continues to be something that
our tim is uh is able to go so
all right let's uh another game
another game for vladislav with the
white pieces but we do remember
that he the only game he's lost so far
was with white so the the lower the time
controls as
and in blitz chess specifically uh
colors don't really matter as much as in
classical games
because there's uh more stuff happening
and
and more um accidents prone to happen
which um which can happen both with
white and with black
as we say in blitz bleep happens
right accidents happen when it comes to
blitz um now g4
is a is a move that says i'm not going
to have this hedgehog just continue to
be one where black and maneuver and
this structure everybody let's bring up
the analysis board real quick to
highlight that
forget sometimes what the engine says
that white's just better black has a
super solid position this is a hedgehog
setup where black can
kind of slowly remaneuver move the rook
and the bishop and kind of relocate
so one of the things white has to do at
some point when you have a big space
advantage just say you know what
i'm not afraid to use it and g4 is a
move that has direct intentions
to turn this space advantage into some
sort of king side attack
and so um we see g4 met by knight c5
from magnus to clear up the d7 square
for the night
but i like this aggressive showing here
hammer by by artemyev to say
i'm ready to get frisky over here in
this hedgehog and see if i can use my
space
yeah it's um but it it can backfire
it's a very committal move white's king
will be left without pawns to defend it
and magnus will try to capitalize on
that while artemia
will try to create an attack on black's
king and just
pretty much cramp black's position
as the white pawns advance there's going
to be less and
less space for the for the black pieces
and this h6 move is a really interesting
psychological ploy from magnus
he's trying to provoke artemyev into
going
h4 after which magnus will play the move
h5 and he's gonna be like oh
oh yeah i was just moving one forward to
provoke you
to go further forward uh and then the
knight will
jump in behind white's pawns to create
lots of of trouble there i love that
idea i just highlight on the board i
learned something from that that's an
instructive little
advanced little pawn maneuver there and
uh
artemia does not take the bait he
switches sides and then plays g5 which
the risk of that
after h6 everyone is the trade kind of
splits the pawns right normally
you would love to have the h-pawn
recapturing here you're forced to take
with the f-pawn where
yes you avoid that knight g4 from magnus
but
you've really as you said hammer this is
an example where the hedgehog could lead
to a crushing win
maybe g6 comes and the position falls
apart
or it could lead to a lot of risky chess
here because white is super committed
opening the king
yeah and g6 definitely was artemia's
plan
and he plays it without thinking for the
fourth
game in a row magnus is down one minute
on the clock
and these white knights are about to
infiltrate uh black's position
uh the the night the point of white's
last move
is trying to eliminate the defender of
the e6
pawn and if magnus loses this e6 pawn
then the other white knight will also
get an opportunity to jump in
in the center and that's just spells
disaster for magnus
and i'm not sure how he's going to keep
control of his light squares
in this situation no i agree with you
totally
and i i feel like this is a weird
position to see the eval only plus one
for white because our human brain of the
hedgehog
feels like white has gotten everything
they desire right they've gotten the
tactics
on the light squares they're taking
advantage of this lack of space from
black and these e6 tactics are
are all too common everyone in games
where white rolls
to a victory in the hedgehog so we'll
see yeah and i was gonna say
i was gonna say i think magnus needs to
bring the king out
magnus is not in the position where you
normally would like to
involve the king but sometimes you just
got to do what you got to do
and that king needs to come out to
defend the pawn
in the middle yeah he chooses not to
take with the king but
that does lose a pawn
i think you were maybe right maybe he
should have taken with the king look at
that
discipline from artemyev doesn't even
take it with the knight brings in the
piece
capable of more damage on the light
squares this looks like a tough game for
magnus
yeah great move from artemy up there
magnus down two minutes on the clock
i mean magnus is getting steamrolled in
this match
he's just so fortunate that he managed
to turn game two around
to equalize the score otherwise i could
easily see artemia being up by
two points maybe even three
uh yeah i mean at this point if he wins
this game
obviously the math is he'll only be up
by one but again if you're just joining
us
the storyline has been artemyev has has
been the guy so far right the score's
level but the x's and o's on the board
have been
magnus fighting for his life and down on
time
pretty consistently today um
this looks like a game acura moves are
going to put this one away hammer so
what is it is it
yeah maybe accurate moves will
finish it but i have no idea what an
accurate move is
i know magnus was intending to give up
his rook
if artemyev brought his bishop into the
fray
uh so probably great decision there
by the russian to use the knight instead
he's not afraid of knight f3
even though it looks kind of terrifying
um yeah because i guess he's just gonna
move the king
yeah let's let's analyze it real quick i
think again hammer's first point about
bishop takes likely being met with rook
takes here is
really interesting because black might
suddenly get some compensation
you know even if he's still worse on the
light squares so the fact that this was
played we said this check not a threat
because in the end you can't take the
rook
before the queen has to be dealt with so
instead magnus plays queen takes c4 holy
holy you know what he's he's all in i
mean magnus is like well i think i'm
gonna lose this one
i have to try to create some tactics but
you see what the computer says in an
equal position
this guy's hanging right there's all
kinds of tactics on the light squares
here the queen is hanging
probably a simple move ends this game
pretty quickly
yeah but magnus is about to give up his
queen
magnus's main problem is the time he's
down to just
10 seconds and here he chooses to
exchange um in wow
and artemis doesn't even take magnus's
queen
he takes magnus's rook and then he takes
the knight
wow that white knight really went on a
crusade against magnus's position there
in in the space of three moves that
knight
took a bishop a brook and another knight
it was the hero of the game and it once
again has given artemyev
uh the lead they say white knighting is
frowned upon these days but in this case
goes all in
takes everything with check before
before recapturing the queen
and just like that the white
knight delivers the goods not only is
artemia up a piece
but he's still still the one on the
attack what what a finish by the way and
again
if you're looking at a model game for
white uh in a hedgehog you might want to
replay
vladislav varchima's performance in this
game a few times so
all right we're back to the uh
the next game vladislav artemyev is
putting on a show right now
magnus carlsen fighting for his life and
i think we're going to i think we're
going to have a thriller today i'm going
to guess
both these matches magnus carlson and
vladislav archamia cara
coming up right after this so you have a
full day of chess tv ahead of you
i think both these matches are going to
give us give us what we what we signed
up for
and i want to make a little point here
danny i
said we have seen magnus's king's pawn
for the last time and guess what the
black rice artemia have got the
advantage
using the karo khan opening two times in
a row
and magnus has gone away from that
opening
he artemia with the black pieces
actually
forced magnus out of his plan a
and here instead magnus's plan b
is a similar position because he
once again appreciates his bishops uh
so magnus with the two bishops trying to
break down
the the solid pawns of artemyev
uh
i was going to say even though what you
said is true you avoided the kero khan
this is a structure that
is eerily similar in some ways right
given the way it went
yeah but the the main thing that's
different from the first two games
is the computer evaluation uh which
during the cover con was mostly
in black's favor as opposed to here
when the computer is a massive fan of
magnus's position right a great point
let's bring up the analysis board just
to highlight the advanced
uh or for those just tuning in hammer's
main point was that magnus had played e4
and
run into artemis kero khan and not only
failed to get advantage was worse with
white
several games in a row hammer called it
if you just tuned in and indeed
magnus agreed it was time to switch so
we went for a semi-slavin
and as i was highlighting even though
the structure is very similar in some
ways to the kero con white has the
bishop pair versus the solid setup
hammer's totally right white space
advantage is completely different here
the grip on the dark squares the huge
pawn storm
this looks like a maybe a rebound game
for carlson who as you said hammer
he doesn't like to lose two games in a
row yeah and
we discussed it before the match started
avoi
getting two wins in a row that's the way
to shake magnus
but it's an incredibly difficult thing
to do
and um uh our tamiya here
under pressure um i would say for the
first time in the match
that's funny because he's the underdog
but i agree with you
13 000 on twitch almost 7 000 on youtube
thanks for being here the day has only
just begun and as you can see
the favorite uh in the in this
particular battle
is uh currently currently trailing but
there's a fort coming
on e5 get your emotes out um
what does black what does mike do on
this this is
really kind of irish he's gonna have to
retreat right with the bishop or the
knight one or the other
yeah i'm gonna guess the bishop moving
away so that you open up for the rook
uh to put pressure into the middle but
i'm not sure
i thought maybe move that bishop to a
defensive position
right instead artemyev has moved it up
uh in an attacking position the problem
with that being that magnus
he controls that part of the board and
now
magnus's pawns are gonna push that
bishop around
until it has nowhere left to go
and uh magnus right now trying to figure
out whether artemyev is a genius
uh planning to sacrifice his bishop to
eliminate the pawns protecting white's
king
or if uh he's just gifting him
uh um a nice position
i i agree with you i love that you said
he's trying to figure out is artania but
genius or is he blundering
his bishop right although what's funny
is i think carlson could even play
bishop e3 here
if you want to be safe subtle and just
hold the big center together
that would prevent lines let's bring up
okay bishop let's bring up the analysis
board to prove my point which is
b4 the big problem with this in a lot of
ways is not just that
this happens but also likely a third
pawn falls so
magnus doesn't play bishop e3 but bishop
b1 is along the same lines of what i was
suggesting just defend the pawn
now this is probably a real threat and i
think artemyev is still in a very tough
spot
having to figure out what to do with
this uh with this situation
and if artemiev now has to give up his
bishop for white's knight
it proves why he should have gone on the
defensive
with his bishop instead of moving it up
the board
right moving pieces into enemy territory
is not always a good idea sometimes you
need to
uh take care of your own situation first
right and i i think we're getting a good
demonstration of that here
i'm showing your idea hammer because
it's it's a great one there that
hammers point is a retreating move was
probably better
just because it actually makes magnus's
life a little more tricky for just pure
example bishop b1 would just lose the
pawn so
um not not totally that simple but i'm
with you it it feels like bishop b4 to
a5 was a
little bit too aggressive there um from
martin and before
he regrets in four games in a row
magnus has been down one minute on the
clock
but we're seeing a turn in the trends
right here
artemia for the first time down on the
clock
down on position as well for the first
time
which is amazing because he's playing
game five
against the world champion but i want to
remind everyone
that maksudu had a 2-2 score
after four games but that's when the
beast
awoke in carlson uh when
uh with the world champion winning 10
games in a row
after that um artemyev
needs to be at his very best throughout
this match uh because magnus he's just
getting warmed up
and he's gonna be able to play amazing
chess
for the next two hours as well uh a one
point lead isn't gonna be enough
for the russian grand master
well said and a good reminder for every
one of what happened in that previous
mug subu match e5
gaining it's so funny to see how well
he's played this center
meeting magnus because i you know maybe
it's not funny i would never play that
well
but i like that he's been patient he
hasn't tried to rush b4 and give our
timmy what he wants which is the
sacrifice back
so just take a note everyone right the
patience he displays with the space
um is really going to make our timbi's
life tough
and if we're looking for a turnaround
hammer this is a big moment for our
champion if he was down on the clock
down in position and it's all because of
what you called
d4 played by magnus instead of e4 so
so if this is a sign of things to come
will this be the game that awakens the
beast
wow and look at magnus's patience i
thought magnus
had the right opportunity to to go
trap that bishop on the edge of the
board but magnus doesn't want
any funky business he doesn't want to
weaken the situation around his own king
and he's just letting that black knight
stay
on the edge and in fact magnus now
threatening g4 the knight has nowhere to
move
and artemium is gonna have to uh
do some uh some special work
uh to get that knight just off the rim
yeah i think we're gonna say do some
gymnastics mental gymnast which
is what he's having to do here he has to
he plays g5
trying to create some sort of uh pole
vaulting jump board get this get this
knife back in here but
i i will hammer will magnus continue to
be patient and keep the knight
deadlocked
f5 is also a move to consider um yeah i
don't think magnus can keep then
the knight out if magnus moves his pawn
forward
then there's to be an exchange of
pawns no maybe the knight let's analyze
it real quick because
there's also this other knight coming
back to d5 right if f5 there's like a
captures and to be careful black has
things like yeah
or coming in yeah oops
yeah a big moment in in the match here
because magnus took
a full minute to consider and it it
appears he didn't find something he was
fully
uh happy with because now artemyev
back in the game has the time advantage
magnus is down on the clock and now g6
from artemyev
is crucial magnus now with a trap if
artemia
captures the white pawn which he's very
tempted to do
then magnus will push his pawn forward
and the knight is trapped on the edge of
the board instead artemia
first gets that escape route for the
knight
and then is gonna try to get it back
into the game
we're gonna have one of those exciting
finishes where both players are down to
20 seconds
this is where magnus excelled in his
previous
match and this is where artemyev needs
to show
that he can do better uh what is going
on
why can you not capture that pawn i have
no idea but
and the pawn is gone i don't know what
magnus was doing i mean h4
was was brilliant and then g4 to follow
gives up the point
that was fascinating i don't we won't
have time to make sense of it because
as you said hammer we're gonna have one
of those exciting finishes here we go
now down a pawn on the board in addition
the
black knights have excellent squares
uh the only problem for black is that
he's completely
cramped up on the bottom um
rows of the board wow
bishop so magnus even though being down
uh wow the attack would have been
opening up for the queen against the
bishop
so tricky and now are timmyev oh and now
the knight is coming out
into the attack and magnus is in trouble
a game where magnus thought he had
everything under control
is turning around for him both players
down to less than 10 seconds
on the clock magnus desperately trying
to get some counter attack
and frankly succeeds with it magnus
eliminating one of black's pawns on the
side
and going after another one uh and
artemia
he gets the chance to get that crucial
second win
in a row but he blunders and magnus with
the extra bishop
now gonna equalize the match yeah we've
said it we said it just as the match was
about to start
magnus has been so good
in the stressful situations and once
again
he shows that he can keep his nerve
as the seconds countdown and his queen
is about to put some hurt on black's
king
and this was a game that could have gone
either way
but in the end uh magnus avoids
losing two games in a row and he takes
the win
i wow you brought it home there and i i
i couldn't agree more how huge that was
because it was that crucial game where
artemyev might have gotten
two games in a row right he might have
gotten that second win
but he fails to do so and we are back to
level
what a game right it was weird because
it was a game we thought magnus was
going to win but then artemi have
completely turned it around
if this is the story line hammer then
magnus is doing what he did against
mogsulu right he's playing better in
those crucial time scrambles
and that doesn't bode well for our
chimney of as the time controls get
faster
but okay a lot a lot of chess left to be
played we still have 30 minutes here in
the five minute portion
just so excited this is so exciting
yeah and remember this may have been the
turning point
in the match magnus uh
can be intimidating uh when he gets his
groove on when he gets
the the small margins in his favor
and once again i want to remember that
after
uh magnus won the fifth game of his
previous match
against matsudulu he actually continued
to win
nine more consecutive games
uh artemyev needs to reset
after that disappointing game he knows
that he
was in a winning position he knows how
close he was
to take a big lead against the heavy
favorite
but now he needs to deal with the
disappointment
of that defeat and and just
move on as if nothing had happened right
and and that is
what's so difficult about the speed
chess format
is because the games are consecutive
because there are no breaks for the
players
having a good mental being able to
to cope with a defeat uh avoiding two
losses in a row
uh it's so crucial right
yeah no and you know we said that i
think our champion does have that
that quality i like to say that the
great ones have which is short-term
memory loss you know they're so
confident they don't tend to dwell on
their mistakes so i
i believe that he has that but this is
going to be a test because that was much
more heartbreaking i think than that
first loss he had
so um all right here we go we've got a
b3 system by the way i just wanted to
bring up the analysis board to back up
because yesterday we talked about
aronian
trying to go full hikaru a few times
with this b3 blitz specialty
but i will say artemia even more than
aronian actually plays these things
right
regularly we know he also placed the
king's indian attack regularly for those
who followed the speech s grand prix
uh that i covered most of the events for
this year so this is not quite uh levon
aronian's approach i'm not not being so
familiar with b3 i actually like the
position artemia has achieved here
um out of the first few moves
uh and those bishops on the side of the
board
i always find fascinating because i tell
people you need to place your pieces
in the middle but in fact bishops are
best when they're on the side when
they're in those piano positions
because they're pointing in towards the
middle
so it's not about where you place your
pieces
it's about what squares they control and
bishops
are of that sort where being on the side
is the way they control towards the
middle
and we see this sort of uh you know
staring contest here between the dark
square bishops artemia plays h4
i really like that move as a way to sort
of expose
black's retreat of the knight to e8 um
magnus might even try to fix that with
the knight g7 i don't know but
but h5 is a is a real threat here um
and okay so he plays bishop g4 to defend
it
but watch out for this uh how does our
timmy approach it here hammer
i would be very tempted to play knight
e5
and there he goes uh the knight putting
pressure on the black bishop putting
pressure on the black knight
a magnus is going to have to exchange
after which the white
queen gets in there into the middle of
the board
a threat combined with the knight on e7
uh there's some scary stuff going on
and we're so connected right now the
psychic invasion of each other like i'm
like i'm like camped in your brain and
you're camped in mind and we're not even
mad about we're like hey how you doing
right
i mean we are all over this i'm
highlighting moves
a split second before you say it um and
now
h5 from artemyev wow magnus
in a bad situation once again
and it's a return to the initial four
games
with uh he played knight f4 up on time
yeah yeah yeah he's back to the uh again
original rd if you're just tuning in was
vladislav up on time
that last game was sort of a a sign of
baby magnus finding it but no we're
right back at a position
our champion is better i agree with you
hammer i think h5 was also possible but
knight f4
pretty good as a tempo move to hit the
bishop and magnus defending
once again
uh and yeah h5 definitely still on the
agenda
for artemyev wow he chooses to
strike on both sides of the board
simultaneously
uh the the white pawn on the side just
pushing its way
up uh it's gonna allow white to get the
rook into play despite not having moved
that rogue
from the corner um and magnus now under
pressure on both sides of the board
and not for the first time in this match
he's gonna be
down two minutes on the clock i've never
seen magnus being uh pressured uh like
artemiev is doing here
on the clock and now should
change queens put the knight in the
center and then
push the pawn forward on the side of the
board
great play from artemia yeah i totally
agree and artemium is
he's one of those guys who has made a
name for himself i think more this year
hammer than
than he would have in other years not
just because of you know online chances
always existed but the focus
like due to the due to the global
pandemic um people
are getting to know this guy and he's uh
russia has a lot of really talented
super gm's who don't always play in in
the elite invitationals and this guy's
one of them
um okay b5 is a reactive move from
magnus i really like that
he's not allowing the a file to become
open but artemia is still better if he
finds the right approach
is it to take and gang up on an isolated
c pawn
is it knight d5 first what do you think
um i'm really unsure it's it's a good
move from magnus he's trying to get his
knight into the middle
of the board right and now knight d4
next from magnus is such a good good
move for him that knight is going to be
so well placed
i don't really see how artemyev is
is going to deal with that i would say
he should put his knight in the center
as well
but then what's next how does he stop
magnus from getting
the knight into d4 i think the answer is
he
can't uh so then the question needs to
be
how does he prepare for magnus
about to move the knight in and i'm not
sure that was
it oh he has rook a2 okay
so with magnus moving the knight up
there's a double threat
of a fork in two directions
uh so but artemia manages to defend
against both those
threats by moving his rook up he needs
to get rid of magnus's knight
pronto um but he can play e3
now okay and he does i like that because
one thing to recognize is 96 might run
into e4 and f3 trapping the bishop so
um where does magnus put that knight if
you go to c6 hammer c5 falls so
i like this move well magnus is going to
put the knight on b5
and now he has the pressure against the
pawn on d3
which is the disadvantage of moving
forward and now magnus has the option of
capturing
said pawn and look at that look at
magnus's eyebrows right there
i'm not sure he had seen that rook move
from artemyev
exploiting the fact that the bishop and
knight couldn't go into that
relationship where they were both
dependent well let's show it on the
announcement
because i want to see the tactic i think
i think i know the answer will show
everyone else i think bishop d3 would be
met by knight f4
yeah that's the idea everyone is the
bishop can't stay on this diagonal
safely
and guard the knight at the same time so
um it was played very quickly magnus
calculating super quickly that he
couldn't take the pawn so just want to
show that for everyone
but but even if he didn't take it hammer
right looking at the analysis board
this is still a position that you know
magnus is holding
whoa c4 um well i think magnus is under
big pressure
uh though i must say magnus was not
expecting
artemia to make that pawn exchange uh
now the night the night comes into play
attacking both the rook and the pawn and
it seems like artemiev is just
shutting down this game for business
trading off the remaining pieces and it
looks as though magnus despite being
under pressure both on the board and on
the clock
uh he's about to secure a draw
and keeping the the match tied
yeah and despite the timing disadvantage
too which we've been highlighting that
magnus was not
um not up on the clock again like he was
in the uh the last game but
if he holds hammer he gets white again
and we've seen how well he
he played in that in that d4 slot so
this is this is a good draw i think for
magnus's black given that he puts
artemia in a position
to prove that he can do the same yeah
and it's
it's not the artemyev we saw earlier
where he he understood that once he has
the time advantage against magnus
he really needs to put pressure uh
artemyev here just
trading pieces despite being a minute up
on the clock
that suits uh calls him just fine
and let's look at the analysis board to
see maybe where he could have gone wrong
because it was right here with the c4
move
where our timmy have made that decision
you said to just start trading and
ultimately he went for this massive
simplification what was the move he
could have gone for on c4 instead is the
question
uh well i wanted e4 um e4 and then maybe
g4 yeah yeah i i was actually going to
go
e5 after i kicked the knight even better
yeah just try to push black's pieces
back right um okay and but instead
magnus got what he wanted and now
they're just having a trade show
rachel on the main board ratios which
are
actually underrated fun by the way if
you ever want to go to a trade
show and just sit in the back you know
we got 500 here just bid bid low anyway
i don't even know if that is a trade
show anyway
would you say twitchcon qualifies as a
trade show
which con is it racial is it i don't
know would you say it qualifies
i guess so i mean stuff you know
um i got some free swag while i was
there which felt good
um yeah so yeah which gun sure
all right here we go we're back in a
slob and again if you're just tuning in
everybody
the early story line magnus played e4
failed against against our champions
carol khan switched to d4
and had a pretty big advantage last game
so with this match leveling out
despite the fact that i think you and i
would agree still hammer that artemia
has played probably overall the better
chess so far right but magnus does seem
to be finding his groove
you know what happened when stella got
her groove back saved tay diggs career
if you know what i'm talking about right
so could be happening right now i
i've been thinking about our last time
broadcasting together danny
and uh a lot of the times you would make
jokes
and i wouldn't laugh at all and i think
part of the reason
is that your references are either too
old for me
which would be devastating for you or
too american
which would be devastating considering
that we're now broadcasting at 9 00 a.m
uh on the east coast right so you need
to tone down your american references
and then start getting with the times
it's europe baby
and stella got her groove back baby and
angela bassett hasn't been heard from
since but
if you don't even get that reference i
don't even know what to tell you all
right
well i'm a european danny okay okay
all right so what happened one night
let's bring up the analysis board i'm
all with you
okay 94 was played by the way everyone
and taking is not an option because
after captures you got a problem here
it's called a pin
and it's gonna win for black so of
course magnus retreats instead
and now we're in this semi-slub not the
same as as game what was that game five
i guess
hammer but where we had the the castles
long from magnus so
what's going on in this relatively
similar symmetrical structure with d5
currently hanging
i don't really know what happens if you
take that point okay i'll i'll show you
this
if queen takes you take here removing
that it did see danny
and you winnie two would check was that
a rhetorical question you tricked me
into pretending you didn't know what was
going on
no because this one i don't know because
i have a bishop about to capture your
knight
and the evaluation bar jumped oh yeah
it's a favor
oh yeah so why can't you take is it oh
maybe it's that's
what i'm asking you danny oh okay i
you know as the i am in the room i can
never tell whether i'm being talked down
to by the gm's i hang out with so
um thank you for giving me real respect
and asking me a question that i failed
to have the answer to
uh but uh magnus decides that
capturing the pawn is too tricky and
instead chooses to uh put some pressure
on the black bishop on the side of the
board
once again i would say for like the
fourth white game in a row
magnus is trying to get the bishop pair
which
of course i'm a big fan of it's just
that magnus hasn't really been able to
do anything with those bishops
thus far yeah it's not the bishop pair
that you uh you write home and tell mom
about they're currently
currently uh
you know back on the back rank so and i
think this
brilliantly demonstrates what i was
talking about in the previous game
that even though the bishops are located
in the middle of the board
in the central files they're pointing
out towards
the edges of the board right and with
bishops it's all about where they're
pointing
not where they're placed so let's go
back to this knight takes d5 thing what
is the reason
yes it's got to be bishop e6
yeah yeah i i would guess that as well
and then when the bishop comes up to
defend with bishop c4
probably knight d6 yeah i was just gonna
say that yeah
putting additional pressure on those
white pieces
but but it is tricky and and so it's
it's optically
optically a little bit trickier to
figure out why knight takes d5 fails
that first meets the eye
bishop b5 can probably be met by knight
a5
although in that case look at this
hammer the bishop is gone from check so
what magnus is doing
is actually threatening to take on d5
for the first time everyone
again reminder taking here would lose
the knight takes c3 with tempo it
removes the defender of the queen
and again i have a little vision zoo
because they say in between move
i take with check so this movement
meso as i like to say not trying to
sound like yes or inter meso jen
yeah yeah exactly exactly janet's an
intermittent
you got a european audience now you
gotta get they know german pronunciation
okay queen takes d5 i like it and again
everybody the point is knight takes c3
you can trade on d8
right because there's no knight takes e2
with chip does that work for you
yeah and i'm wondering what was
artemia's plan against this
uh because he just lost the pawn
straight up
no cap as my kids would say straight up
lost a pawn no cap
you know what that means or am i cooler
than you all of a sudden
i i i have i'm familiar with the
expression yes thank you
my 15 year old told me last night when i
said no cap at dinner he said you're no
longer allowed to say that
you you are you anyway
um people are like 15 year old what
yeah trickiness is about to happen here
yes
uh artemia just offered a knight
to magnus um and what's happening then
because if you capture the knight the
bishop is going to force the white queen
away i think we're going to need the
analysis board for this
yeah let's do it let's bring it up
bishop takes c6
oh okay he didn't play but bishop takes
c6 was going to be met by bishop e6 i
assume no i don't think so danny because
then the queen can move
right and then when the rook captures
you get that pawn with a fork do i have
the fork emote
you're not wrong although i don't know
that actually
winning i think black has weird moves
that he's maybe holding on with
either way magnus he makes this i guess
mature decision not to go all in
retreats and says hey
i didn't need your knight because i won
a pawn
yeah and he's respecting the bishops
which i respect
i love that he respects the bishop you'd
respect him a lot of respect flowing
around by the way the threat in that
position was e6 trapping
the unrespected lady in the center so 95
frees the f3 square as a retreating move
yeah so magnus got the pawn but his
queen
got stuck in a precarious situation
and now artemyev is about to kick that
queen
back and then try to get back the pawn
he
what the he's got bishop before dude
that's the idea
but why is the computer still giving
advantage for white
i have no idea that trouble nineteen you
have stuff
the queen gets out there's a counter
threat against black's queen
the temple analysis board analysis board
the point everybody is if knight takes
you get here
and if you take the queen i still end up
being up material
or do i am i just down a piece no i'm up
the exchange i forgot i have two rooks
and if you take with the rook i guess
it's queen e6
i don't know and artemia chooses to do
neither of those things
what is going on
double check there's no by the way no
queen g8 everyone because night guards
f7
but magnus got his queen out of a bad
situation
while simultaneously defending his
knight
on the edge of the board and right now
artemia is down
two pawns and a rock in exchange for
a knight and that's just not good enough
well and he's rubbing his eyes i'm the
guy who woke up at 4 am buddy
um let's bring back the analysis board
to show how crazy that was this move
queen c7
i think was based on knight h6 check
maybe
maybe our timmy have just missed queen
g5 straight up everyone queen g8 was not
a threat because the knight guards f7
don't fall for a failed venus flytrap
i think artemis just missed queen g5
just based on his reaction right hammer
well he must have and now magnus pushing
the pawns forward in the center
this is a highway uh to the win
and for the first time in this match
magnus is gonna take the lead who had
that on their bingo cards
magnus taking the lead in game
seven first of all you just referenced
bingo and
and i love you for it just mark that off
my bucket list somebody else makes an
unnecessary pop culture reference on a
chest show um
that was great no you're right who had
that and again hammer's not joking
everyone
magnus has not led in this match that's
likely going to change right here
and hammer i feel like you're pro this
is why we had you with these magnificent
matches
just for show knight f7 just for show
queen e5 and then knight oh queen of
five and then knight f7 let me let me
show it on the analysis board
you predicted it so well he does it
knight f7 and the knight is pinned
everyone
uh okay even better night g4
even better
and magnus about to win this game
about to take the lead in the match and
artemyev has given away
a lot of big chances so far
uh he needs to let that slide
uh mental uh uh acuity
that's what it's all about now and and
he needs to
um just concentrate on the position
ahead of him
and and forget all about the
numerous chances he has had uh
to uh to get the the up on
on magnus yeah it's hard it's
easier said than done right although
there is only 10 minutes left before a
break so maybe
with a chance to refresh himself before
he wrecks himself
artemyev will uh we'll play some good
chess on the three one portion he's
already kind of over performed what uh
the
smarter chess predictions were for the
five-minute portion
saying magnus should be three games
better so take that smarter chess
uh by the way go to chessgoals.com you
can use the command chess goals so even
though we make fun of smarter chess go
ahead and
head over to chess goals and get
guidance towards your chess improvement
a lot of a lot of us need that we got 22
000 of you
plus on twitch 9 000 of you almost on
youtube
and we love every one of you literally
hammer loves every one of you
like yeah look at that smile
um and this might be the very last game
uh of the five minute portion
which means if magnus is able to
take two in a row and get an amazing
finish
in the five minutes once again
the the results will uh
lie about what's going on in the match
because this five minute uh section has
been all about
what is yet the score
doesn't accurately reflect that because
magnus has been the best player
in the crunch uh when uh you're down
on time and um and yeah
i i think it's absolutely crucial for
our temiev now
to uh to make sure that he's uh
at least with a draw here uh in this
game
uh to uh to feel like he's still within
striking distance
of of magnus going into the three-minute
portion
i like i like that you said that because
i think it's good chess advice
uh as a guy who's played in world elite
events speaking for you
sometimes you just gotta stop the
bleeding so you're saying artemia
even a draw is okay now he is white of
course he'd love a w
and tie this thing before the three
minute portion starts but sometimes your
mindset has to be like hey
all right i know i've missed
opportunities but don't don't let this
thing
slip away don't tilt don't tilt early um
and 85 is that about g5
uh g5 danny i'm not sure
i like your chess instincts a g5
looks horrible the black king already
with a white rook pointing down towards
it
now you want to weaken its positioning
once you get castled
let's see what the engine thinks who
agrees with it analysis board we go
let's see who likes g5
oh so you're just telling me okay you
were right
the engine likes white on g5 okay um
what were we talking about again once
again danny i want to say
uh you know your confidence is admirable
if
misplaced thank you well um
knight e5 does threaten to take d7 just
to explain my thought process you can't
take with the knight because it's pinned
and if you take with the queen i take on
f6 and double your pawn so i'm trying to
deal with that
maybe i just back up to e7 it threatens
pretty much
everything danny but i'm wondering what
happens on bishop c3
that has to be the the attempted
punishment oh let's do it
now if the bishop can get in there
uh both the rook and no
strike that danny uh artemy have just
sacrificed his rook
knight d takes c4 what the bleep look at
that bishop takes e1 is met with knight
to d6
and the wtf's hit the chat why the face
why the face magnus
but is magnus now just gonna castle
magnus's king is in a real state right
now
but uh on the other hand the computer
evaluation uh is very
much more black than white meaning that
black with the best moves should have an
advantage
that being said white has all of these
pieces pointed in towards
uh black's uh queen towards black's king
towards pretty much everything and in
addition to that
magnus is severely down on time he's
down
two and a half minutes on the clock
uh with his king in trouble uh
this might be the epic comeback
and the kind of win artemiev needs right
now
if he can win in style equalize the
score going into the three-minute
portion he's gonna be on a real high
with magnus wondering what on earth just
happened
this man just completely annihilated me
well b5 is played wtf now means
where's the fork because it no longer
exists the bishop guards d6
but there is no chekaruski here um
b5 is a heads up i mean look at this
position there were a lot of ways it
could go wrong taking e1
allowing this move would have been bad
for magnus as i showed quickly
uh castles is bad because the king gets
blown open and
and here we go so magnus finds the cool
headed b5
kicking the knight while you guard d6
and this rook is still hanging so i know
you went
i know you went hype champ over there on
artemium's comeback but i'm gonna say
i think magnus is going to kenbe mutumbo
on that not in my house
look at that move b5
people outside of no that's not entirely
true
but i'm not too familiar with basketball
hey the u.s is kind of the home of
basketball
every doorway norway rising basketball
capital of the world you
i called it here 20 30. um anyway um
be fine i i think i deserve
some credit just for knowing that that
guy was a basketball player
that's probably because you've
subscribed to my channel and you got
that mutumbo emo now you talk because i
get to use my emote for the first time
today
uh but artemia now taking a long
think uh there's so many pieces
under attack right now and vladislav
is going to have to give up at least one
of them
um but the question is
which one he opens up for the rogues on
the edge of the board
uh he's probably gonna make the trade
and what's happening then is magnus
gonna move the queen
away from the protection of the king
i have no idea what's going on but
artemia really
should have an idea because he spent two
and a half
minutes considering the uh
consequences of his play
yeah and the time is still undecided
it's gone
right um you were highlighting earlier
the time advantage and
its position is still close to level
although it's one of those level
positions according to the computer and
humans are like
what is going on here there's a million
pieces hanging and
so this is one of those positions i'm
just going to predict the next move
within the next three moves the eval bar
hammer
is just going to go nut like someone's
going to blunder here you can't maintain
balance and time pressure
in such a nutty position yeah but i
think artemia is going to blunder
because the fact that he spent so much
time means that he cannot find anything
he's happy about
which means he's probably just gonna end
up in a bad
position and the eval bar supporting
that
in the first uh in the first move
magnus actually moving his queen away
from the king
despite the king desperately needing
protection
uh he's magnus is just happy to get that
queen
away from white's bishop that was
pointing in
uh dangerously towards the queen
yeah you i mean you called it and i've
been i was highlighting taken with the
queen because of the battery earlier and
now i wonder if that pawn
is just capturable by the way with only
a minute left more than likely this is
the last game of the time control one of
your last chances to subscribe throw us
your prime
to see what happens in our prime time
smackdown this week we got
wrench versus hammer a couple of tools
huh a couple of tools in the old tool
shop
throwing around wrench and hammer
and i think magnus should castle now to
get the king into safety and he does
do that magnus now with the safer king
with the better pawn structure with more
time
on the clock yes he's a pawn down but
look at those bishops pointing in
towards white's position
we've had a big turn around magnus was
on the defensive
now he's given up upon gotten his king
into safety
and now it's his bishops ruling the
board
creating trouble for artemyev and it's
looking as though magnus is about
to get two in a row here finishing the
five minute time control
of really seizing the moment uh and uh
getting a big advantage going into the
first break
well said it'd be it would oh
uh magnus moving in the forces towards
white's king artemyev tries to do the
same with his queen
but oh there was a knight magnus just
captures the knight
and with that he wins a piece
uh he tries to create some counter
checkmating threats here artemyev
but magnus moving his knight back seems
to have
things under control because now
you can capture the rook i was going to
say even bishop c8 was a funny move
anyway but what he does is good enough
clearly
artemia runs out of pieces and magnus
winning two in a row we talked about how
crucial it is
to to get that a big advantage of of
tilting the opponent
while at the same time getting a solid
lead
in the match magnus just did it he had a
slow start
but he's getting there and he's going to
be lethal
in the three-minute portion as well it's
crucial for artemyev
to keep this distance of just two points
magnus is capable of running away with
it and and that has to be
uh artemia's artemyev's priority right
now to to just
stop this good face magnus is in
uh well said it and i and i do agree
that if artemia keeps it close the
bullet could be anyone's game because
vladislav
is so effective as a as one of the top
bullet players
on chess.com so all right you set the
table for what three minute needs to be
for both these guys i'll set the table
for the break prime time smackdown
between wrench and hammer coming your
way
uh don't go anywhere everyone when we
return it's more speed chess
championship on this double header day
today
we'll be back in just a few minutes
[Music]
okay hammer are you ready to are you
ready to feel bad about yourself
i just want to say that when my kids
when i get kids i want them to be as as
bold and brave as you
volunteering to play me in a bullet
match
knowing you're gonna get destroyed right
it's it's it's an admirable trait
well i've also people have also said
like danny how come
you have no pride how come you
self-deprecate so much how come you put
yourself
in masochistic situations so you want
them to have those straights too
this is the i suppose i'm eating i guess
dude i know this is going to sound
shocking to you and the audience
i don't plan on losing to you bro i
don't plan on
let's go ready okay let's go
oh my god i forgot you play this crap
what is your deal
yeah how about that you like that about
that how about that
how about uh no this is a winning
position for white like yeah that's
right i forgot you play crap
you play crap and then you know the crap
so well that it's hard to compete
with the crowd i think that's you will
find that's a pawn
up for me i'm up to here with your crap
how about that
ah interesting a bad move by you
have your pawn thank you this is one of
those
positions that should be worse for me
than it is but you messed up so bad
because you're so distracted by me
i think you will find that's not really
what's happening here
i think you will find that you need to
respect the bishops
and you have failed to do so in this
game i need to respect the bishops
i don't need to respect the bishops you
need to respect the bishops
i am though
he thought you were going to get d4
check
i actually did give you d4 check
that was so irritating oh it's so funny
oh my gosh okay thank you
i was so focused on fast fun
do i hate you i hate you right now i
hate you so much
no i mean i can even tell you what moves
you should play and you still don't play
them
i wasn't even looking for d4 anymore i
had too much i
i literally made you aware that was an
option okay well guess who gets the
white pieces now bro
and we are back here yet again as the
first
speed chess championship match of the
day between magnus carlson and vladislav
artemyev
moves to the three-minute segment but
not before we remind all of you
to move your schedules tomorrow it's
tgif it's bob battles
we got younger and creepier john
travolta
on the left along with uh
you know something robert hess would
never look like which is organized and
clean-shaven on the right it's gonna be
quite the day tomorrow hammer
uh yeah i'm looking forward to it i i i
maintain that robert's
uh depiction was was pretty decent
at least compared to yours but you know
i mean your body is going to get
one hell of a beating tomorrow
that's a european reference and i'm
going to continue making european
references
for the rest of this match okay okay
yeah
all right predictions we've got
we've got three minutes coming up here
um
again six to four predicted in the
three-minute portion uh we've
again magnus carlsen is the favorite and
pretty much every time control but as
you said artemia really just needs to
focus on
stop the bleeding don't tilt even if you
keep it within just a couple games for
bullet
the fastest segment maybe where you have
to make your move right
yeah all right now having lost two games
in a row
it's all about uh mental and being able
to just continue
how he's been playing so far without
thinking too much about the
disappointing results he's had
honestly the the three minute the five
minute section
was evenly matched uh if anything i
would say artemiev was maybe the better
player
but magnus showing his uh
how good he is in those decisive moments
takes or comes away with a two
game lead uh meaning that
um if he can just continue this
trend uh he's gonna win the match
also showing how much he can pack it in
right there magnus had a real cheek fold
there that's a nice strong jaw when you
can fit that much food in your mouth
and still managed to chew it down with
no swelling did you see that the picture
he had on facebook danny
he had his birthday brunch a couple of
days ago
that that plate was packed i i'll tell
you
yeah well uh all right we're gonna have
a packed show for the rest of the day so
don't go anywhere still
more than half ahead and then we have
nakamura versus fedo say it but
here we go the three minute begins in uh
five four
three two one we have liftoff
and magnus once again starting with the
white pieces
but he has been moved off his plan a
uh initially he was playing the the king
pawn openings
but artemyev's karo khan was just
too strong and magnus chose
to switch uh to the the queen pawn
openings
now i'm not seeing magnus make any moves
here and his e and his connection bar
has dropped big time right
yeah is he even aware the game has i
don't think so maybe the team can give
him tell him to refresh or something he
seems to have uh
lost connection with the oh there he
goes now he's oh wow
and now he's very unhappy yeah i don't
know what happened there
he lost his connection and now is he
aware it's his move or
and a decision has been made okay we're
gonna we're gonna restart the game
apparently
not not apparently it wasn't wasn't
magnus's uh fault there i think we're
gonna abort and restart the game
there we go okay so something happened
there but either way all is well that
restarts well as far as the chess.com
server goes am i right
all right let's uh let's keep this thing
stable and clean today everybody
um and once again magnus using that
queen pawn
because that has given him the results
he needs
the king pond not helping out today the
queen pawn
put to the test and magnus uh i think
he won two white games in a row uh and
he's going to try to
continue that trend yep he plays
uh this c6 and e6 carol khan often that
being vladislav artemia by the way this
is something we've seen him do
on a regular basis he also employs the
a6 slav
um for those of you just wondering about
artimus repertoire he's very consistent
i'll say that some players on line
hammer
are kind of all over the place but
artemia vis is
is not gonna vary i think from the slav
all day
even if magnus has success that's not
really his style
and he loves putting his pawns on the
light squares
both against the queen pawn openings but
also the king pawn openings
and here he's only one move away
from having all eight pawns on the light
squares
but that would bode poorly for his
uh light squared bishop which is
currently trapped in behind
all of these pawns so he's gonna need to
breathe some life into that uh bishop's
uh potential and
he's decided to do so by trying to go
e5 so moving his rook in towards the
center
clearly he's intending to move the pawn
forward
which will also be very helpful to his
bishop
which then gets a root out of
its uh misery yeah and what you
highlighted is is the typical way this
structure goes right it starts out
passive everyone but very often
i was just going to say b3 is a great
move that stops it very often the plan
when the exchange happens is for black
to kind of liberate the pieces
with either e5 or c5 in this case he
doesn't
have to do it because magnus traded so
he takes with the e pawn
making sure at some point the light
square bishop will have life maybe on
this f5 square but what did magnus get
in the meantime
pressure against the c6 pawn so instead
the bishop stays
stays passive and tucked away defending
yeah
really interesting position and i want
to point out
that one of the most difficult things
about the speed chess format
is adjusting to a new time control these
guys have been
spending the last hour and a half
playing five minute games
but now time has been cut they're down
to
three minutes each and magnus has not
really um his mind
hasn't communicated to his hands that we
need to speed up
because magnus once again down on time
but it's much
more precarious in the three minute
games
because you get into time trouble sooner
my mind also has trouble communicating
in my hand on a regular basis um
but in this case i'll leave that alone
um bishop to b2 played kind of passive
here i think that i think that our
teammate has gotten the better of the
opening right let's bring up the
analysis board and if we just go back to
that position you first mentioned
on rookie 8 with the tension in the
pawns magnus chose to break it himself
by trading on on on d5 but
now we notice again as the bishop
eventually came to b7
c5 is on the agenda for black he gets it
well timed and uh
and yeah oh my god we need to move to
the board our attention
has sacrificed i want to move
and magnus is shaking his head
artemia removing the pawn in front of
white's king
the knight could have been captured uh
but then white's king would have gone on
a
journey that it was probably a mating
journey
if you ask me right uh yeah so magnus
instead
chooses to just uh move the rook
and what is going on artemyev leaving
the night
where it is because he knows he has the
capture
and then the knight attacking both the
king
and the bishop and artemyev doing all
the tactics right now
he's gonna end up with a pawn extra
in addition to having weakened the
defenses around
magnus's king well
trying to show the positional advantages
of artemia backfire because i missed the
moment on knight takes f2 but let's go
back to the analysis board again i want
to show it because we did miss it in
real time with the show the whole point
was magnus blundered
with d takes c5 missing knight takes f2
again as we said king takes would have
gotten mated and walked up the board
the magnus just tucks his tail between
his legs and knows he's going to lose a
pawn
and with it as hammer said black has the
extra peshka
and the compensation the dark squares
are weak along with e3
and what what a move right now from
artemia that knight takes f2 and
he could he could bring this back within
a game here yeah i'm proud of our temiev
uh showing his strength there i'm also
proud of you danny
with the peshka european reference uh
that's russian
russian yeah russia is
in europe you didn't know that right uh
right i mean there's a guy that spent
some time there and i speak a little bit
of russian
i don't like i mean i'd i'd rather you
refer to us by the proper name of
eastern europe
okay that's fine
as long as it's got europe in it i'm
proud of you for
uh expanding your horizons on the
references okay well you're welcome
in this position uh artemyev is going to
have trouble expanding his horizons if
white maintains control of the dark
squares it's funny magnus defended
despite all the hype there pretty well
right i mean
he's going to have the d4 square for the
queen and the knight this bishop
isn't ideal as long as the pawn chain
kind of stays this way
so i think magnus is defended decently
given that just outright blunder of
knight takes up two
uh yeah but being a down a pawn is still
a problem
and the the pawn magnus has on e3
that's uh a loner right there it's what
we call an isolated pawn
that is um it cannot be defended by its
other pawn
peshka buddies uh which
means no no when we refer to plural it's
pesh key
there you go by the way no way i'm
getting corrected on russian grammar
right
sorry speaking of the pesky despite
artemia having an extra one i actually
still like how magnus defended this pawn
is more of a target and a blocker
right of this bishop here i i'm with you
but i feel like magnus has
recovered nicely and could hold this
especially with the mutual time pressure
coming
yeah uh no i agree uh great defense from
from magnus um if somewhat cooperative
from our temiev yeah and magnus now
just uh trying to control
both sides of the board with his bishop
um ooh but artemia with the bishop
coming into c4
and then he's gonna get his king
involved
is a tricky guy he has not given up hope
uh here just yet yeah this is a really
strong idea everybody because
let's just foreshadow if the bishop has
to leave this diagonal
look out for the king to run in so
magnus is desperately trying to hold the
a4
e8 diagonal artillery of trying to find
a tricky way to get the king in
but are tamiya really down on time
yeah and magnus trying to exploit that
um might even try to get an undeserved
win
here uh but on the other side wow
artemia is
doing a good job on the king side uh
it doesn't seem to be enough though he
has a past pawn
um but he's struggling to get that pawn
uh past white's king and it looks as
though
magnus has successfully defended and
will get a draw
yeah not not a hundred percent yet but
i'm with you it
again this bishop is holding two
diagonals every one entry
along the b1 h7 point entry along the a4
e8 point
it doesn't seem possible for black to
get the bishop off of both especially
with d5 as a target and the threat of
the king coming up so our champion is
not
this is what you got to do right we got
to applaud him you don't you don't happy
for a draw against the world champion
you got to push this
um despite it probably just you know
being a draw
yeah but at the same time i feel like he
was way too cooperative
in the exchanges leading
uh to this end game where um
where he just let magnus do what magnus
wanted to do
right uh and and get this very blocked
position where
magnus manages to defend despite being
upon down
hold on rex
our timmy was trying to check the king
out so the king can get in
yeah magnus now lowest on time just two
seconds remaining
hold the horses it's whoa what
only one magnus made that with point
five on the clock by the way
okay now he seems to have recovered on
the increment he almost almost had the
draw
uh artemia actually offered it and and
magnus declined it but they they
reach at the old-fashioned way with
perpetual so
i i'm with you i think magnus um that
was more of a moral victory for magnus
than anyone else
because artemia was the one holding the
cards and he kind of let magnus have his
defensive way with it
yeah i i think artemyev has been
brilliant
in this match he's just not using the
chances he's getting
and you know at this level you get
punished for that you don't get that
many
chances against magnus and you gotta
take them while they're there
yeah robert and i say this a lot in
commentary that sometimes you lose these
matches
not just with blunders but you're missed
opportunities right more than anything
else and
um that could be one that comes back to
haunt him
sure
and once again i feel like artemyev
i mean it's tough to say
i mean playing against magnus but i feel
like he's being the better player
it's just that he's he's giving away
a lot of points in those crucial time
scrambles
and magnus he's so lethal he takes
advantage
time and time again and that's why he's
up two points on the score
yeah and one of the things we say about
both magnus and hicarro
and others too but those two guys are
always on the top of your brain when
you're talking about these
blitz events is is that they they're the
guys who probably
they do two things well they they
convert most on those time scramble
opportunities and they persevere the
best when they're worse they create
those resourceful traps and so
it ends up being the storyline you said
after the five minute where the
scoreboard
five to three magnus after five minute
wasn't necessarily reflective of the
quality of chess but the scoreboard is
what matters right magnus held and got
the points when it counted
and um one sign
of magnus being under pressure in this
match is how many times he's been down
on the clock and uh as we proceed to the
quicker time controls
uh being down on the clock is going to
be uh a growing
disadvantage and here uh our temiev
uh he was up 30 seconds now it's down to
10 seconds
but those small time advantages do
matter and um and he just needs to
to start taking the opportunities he's
getting
in the time scrambles uh because he's
he's playing well
and he's he's uh creating trouble for
magnus
through his time management
well said we had about 26 000 of you
there on twitch we've got 8 000 of you
on youtube just tv we see you over there
thank you everyone for your support
and uh thanks for being here we still
got a long day ahead i see some people
asking when hikaru plays he plays
right after this match and for those of
you that were with us very early we
actually had about a 10 minute delay due
to some
fair play technical difficulties so it
won't be too long of a break after this
match before hikaro and fedo say
kick off so uh thanks for being with us
on this will now be an scc thursday
yeah what a day yeah
all right we've got it good
well i i was going to talk about the
finished match which is maybe
inappropriate considering that
we got magnus playing right now and
actually i changed my mind because we're
gonna have to talk about the fact
that magnus is already down to one
minute on the clock
despite their not even having been
played 20 moves total
in this game uh magnus's time management
has been complete shambles and it just
feels like a question of time
before he's um he's punished for it
i like this move rook c8 by the way was
threatening a common kind of hedgehog
tactic of knight d4 let's show it on the
analysis board because
the advanced players it's a little bit
of an important point something like
this played you have to watch out for
this see the computer loves it for black
you take with the c
pawn win the bishop pair and usually
have the compensation with it so
artemia immediately plays queen b1 on
rook c8
good little tactical pattern it
brilliantly illustrates that top players
never like having their queens on the
same
file as their opponents wrote right and
precisely that theme is what artemy have
used now
to open up the position and put pressure
on magnus
because magnus made the mistake of
putting his queen
on the same file as the white rook and
as a consequence of that
um artemiev got his bishop in a good
position
pointing down towards black's camp
and now also involving the knight uh
artemyev still up 50 seconds
on the clock um is this gonna be
his comeback game uh in that case he can
equal
well he cannot equalize the match but he
can get it down
to a one point lead for magnus but just
as importantly
it will be a huge boost to his
uh his mental that he's been able to to
cut magnus's lead
and put pressure on him continuously in
these
three-minute games yeah couldn't agree
more and no bishop d6
is releasing the titan if you will over
here on the queen size she's got our
eyes on the b6 pawn and magnus now down
to 20 seconds
again yeah magnus is in huge trouble
yeah and that is
the comeback game artemia's going to get
it it's going to happen now
into in the time pressure we see magnus
kind of shaking his head just
just frustrated with the way he's played
since the start of the three minute
portion you had a freudian slip a minute
ago partner where you almost said that a
win by artemia would tie the match
and that tells you how we feel today
everybody artemiv is right there almost
like he should have won last game right
i mean this is artemiev's
i think he has the ability to keep this
thing close
and now he needs to be careful about his
bishop the bishop is retreated
and magnus inviting the end game despite
being down
a pawn should tell you how much magnus
trusts
his ability in end games
and artemyev i dislike how he's been
spending so much time here the last
couple of moves you should just
get that bishop into e7 attack the black
rook
and then come in with the knight as well
magnus being uh pressured here
uh by by black by white
and it feels as though this is artemis
game
uh but he he wasted his time advantage
he spent too much time
and despite being 40 minutes up now he's
uh
down by 10 seconds and magnus trying to
get
uh rid of as many pieces as he can to
to equalize the um
this game yeah now he's trying to get
the the pair of bishops
off because the knight would probably
hold its own okay with all the pawns on
one side of the board
again no way artists bishop is trapped
it's going to
cannot get out well wait magnus has more
than a draw
no it's gonna be equal but whoa wait a
second
oh my gosh suddenly black is the one
playing for a win here and i was just
gonna say
despite everything we've talked about
magnus puts himself in a position
to persevering being resourceful that
the result of this game is not going to
end
to indicate uh what most of the moves
showed us which was our timmy have
played like a boss but
but like you said hammer he's losing it
in these time scramble crucial moments
and
i really dislike that he spent all his
time advantage he had
one minute to 20 seconds and he spent it
all
without really figuring stuff out
i think this game is still going to be a
draw but artemyev
continuously being down to just seconds
on the clock
that's uncomfortable yeah and he you
could easily see him
uh getting into trouble uh and uh maybe
even uh
losing uh and now here's the pressure
magnus is currently putting on white's
pawns
and note that magnus is kind of in that
position with house money here hammer
right even though i agree with you
objectively should be a draw
the two pieces are better than the rook
everyone when everything is stuck to one
side of the board the rook would rather
flex
with multiple past pawns these sort of
things so so
magnus can play this position even if he
can't win for quite some time
and with very little risk
yeah and i mean he's up by two in the
match
so uh spending time on the clock makes
sense
as a match strategy but it also makes
sense as a way
of putting pressure on artemyev who is
very low on time and continuously has to
figure out how to deal with
these new plans magnus is using and now
magnus all the way
trying to put his bishop on the same
diagonal as white's uh
oh oh uh yeah i was getting nervous
you saw me i tend to grab my hand i'm
nervous i'm working on it
well i thought artemia can go and grab
this pawn on the side
ah magnus going f5
f5 is not a good move i do not like that
move
yeah it it undoubles and helps white
should still be a draw but this position
is
getting a little more double-edged yeah
i guess it was necessary for magnus to
do that
uh but artemia getting his king involved
look how tricky the position whoa he was
almost frozen there elsa
white white uh almost put him in six one
okay and
our tamiya is exchanging down to draw a
nice
end this thing the old-fashioned way huh
get get down to just kings and we have a
draw wow
what a mess there um but magnus again
the storyline
snatching stalemate from the jaws of
defeat holding on
yeah but i think what artemia's problem
is now he needs to exploit
magnus being slow to adapt to the new
time control
and now he's wasted two good chances in
a row
we've seen how lethal magnus is towards
the
end of these uh time sections
because that's when he has adjusted uh
to the to the time control and i think
the more uh artemyev now uh
doesn't manage to cut down on magnus's
lead
i i think magnus is gonna have a really
good showing
in the last 20 15 minutes of the three
minute portion
so uh artemyev needs to strike while
magnus's time management is still
um
yeah the uh the time management
tends to change the storyline as we get
into bullet right and
sometimes the guy that's been taking a
lot of time magically speeds up in the
fastest segment but
i'm with you that overall if artemia
keeps this within a game or two
i feel like the bullet is is quite the
coin flip our tim you have so
so many games on chess.com one of the
best bullet players
um i think you'll have his chances there
and this is going to be an exciting one
because uh artemia have just sacrificed
a pawn
on the side of the board and magnus has
taken the challenge
he took the pawn or tamiya trying to
claim that
opening up for his rook is going to give
him a long-term
compensation uh long-term chances for
the pawn
um but we'll just have to wait and see
bishop comes back after stealing the
pawn but artemiev has compensation as
hammer said based on pressure here
pressure on the b file but his pawn is a
pawn
and what does artimus do now to prove it
because this is one of those positions
it becomes kind of benko gambidish you
give white moves
it's queen c2 the rook goes to e1 or d1
we develop and rook b1
so artemia has to find a way to get
long-term compensation now before white
develops and coordinates
yeah and what he just did was a good
move that queen
pointing in towards white's king is
going to force
magnus to hide out in the corner yeah um
and then you need to get you know the
rest of the pieces involved let's show
the analysis
real quick why queen v6 is such a thorn
you can't really develop the bishop to
e3 without b2 falling
if you make some random move here comes
knight e4
problems with pins on the diagonals so
queen b6 a very tricky little move there
from martinez and as hammer said the
king tucks itself
to bed in the quarter and now artemia is
going to play bishop a6
uh putting the bishops up against each
other while
simultaneously getting ready to get the
rook
uh that's currently next to black's king
get that
over to the other side because that's
where black
is attacking right now i played bishop
a6 on the analysis board but we see
there on the live board above the
players queen b4 was played
and now we've got this position where
black is putting pressure on e4 before
trying to
make some exchanges i i'm not sure what
you think about that um
interesting yeah these
these uh pawn sacrifices are very tricky
and i think they're difficult to play
for both sides
um yeah i felt like artemyev needed to
get that bishop out
and go for the trade because it's not
really clear
where that light squared bishop is going
to find a good home
uh but artemyev has decided to keep him
uh the bishop on d7 now
once again getting out of the way as the
work
enters the fray uh and magnus strikes
magnus strikes in the center with his
pawn
forcing uh artemyev on the defensive
and magnus's pawns will be weak they're
going to be
attacking targets for black but recall
that magnus is
up a pawn uh so he can even lose upon
without it being a problem
whatsoever look at this move bishop e3's
pointing out that the d6 pawn has more
to worry about than just the e5 punt
but artemyev doesn't miss a beat says i
got you bishop f5
yeah but magnus is gonna sacrifice his
rook now
oh man talking dirty to me now you know
how i feel about exchange sacrifices
come on um but why
uh because uh he moves
you get a really nice center
oh okay so magnus trades first but i
think it just transposes to the
variation i was
thinking about well let's analyze the
show i think you're anticipating rook
takes
whoa i thought rook takes would be the
case but let's knight takes was just
played
yeah i was not expecting that yeah i was
expecting brook takes and then i thought
your line would be something like takes
here
and i don't even know that you have to
sack the exchange because my point is
that there's moves like 94 with huge
centers and c5 problems so
maybe that's what first of all this
thing called uh a submission
oh that's right we talked about that
sorry i'm still struggling with your
european language
rook takes bishop takes c5 and then
bishop takes b1 was your idea
although funnily enough do i have moves
like this and try to trap your rook in
some cases
maybe or maybe not
maybe i just but we got to get back to
the game yeah we've got to get out
of being exchanging stuff the queens are
off the board
the the pawns are off the board
magnus with two pawns on the left hand
side
is going to try to get a new queen or
something
and both players down on time yet again
uh magnus with the worst of it but we've
seen how
magnus when he's down to 20 seconds
manages to speed up in the crucial
moment
leaving artemyev to make the mistakes in
the time scramble
agreed agreed agreed knight c4 played
kind of irritating you're threatening
forks on d2
as well as tactics on b2 and a3 with the
bishop
but okay lots to calculate
brooks c1 only 11 seconds for magnus or
timmy of grabs back the pawn i'm liking
artie's chances here yeah that knight
coming into d3 is
nasty yeah and artemia artemyev coming
with and magnus sacrifices his rook
in an attempt to create complete chaos
on the board uh artemia responds with a
rook sacrifice of his
own artemia currently up by a knight
uh in exchange for a pawn uh danny
resizing the board at the right moment
yet again
and uh but it seems like artemyev it
gets a hold of that white pawn
that was one square away from uh
becoming a new queen and once that pawn
is removed from the board it does seem
like this is
our tamiya's moment his sacrifice in the
opening about to pay
off as his knight moves to the edge of
the board
to eliminate the last pawn from magnus
and he goes after the pawn magnus tries
to give a check
artemyev gets the king away wow magnus
is fighting
yeah he is he's making it tricky
wow what is going on here i have no idea
i mean i should be winning but
classic madness only two seconds with a
knight
yeah winning with a knight against lots
of pawns is a
very difficult task right because the
knight is such
and he's going to kick the king back
with h4 at some point
look at him just sitting tight here
making artemia figure it out with
with only the increment really on the
clock oh and our teammate is going to
play h4
no oh what a nice idea by the way look
at the night
a unicorn if you if you will yeah
everything
what about oh and magnus magnus is upset
he didn't
have this idea brilliant play from
artemia
absolutely managed to get his knight in
a defensive position
magnus is furious with himself let's
bring up the analysis board again and
magnus is furious artemia brings this
thing back to within a game
and really the maneuver that was uh that
took this game everyone was remember
how much how much artemia was struggling
as long as this knight
was trying to guard the a pawn so
instead artemia realizes
the knight is best over here where it
can hold these squares
preventing the king from coming in this
is super instructive seriously
the the knight eventually figures out
that e6 is the square for the future
and this frees up the black king to go
be the guy
who bullies the pawn just an absolutely
brilliant technique
magnus unable to break the blockade
missing this idea of captures and h4
and it's over because you don't have
time to go after the h pawn with knight
g5
guarding protecting and uh and magnus is
busted so
okay back to the live game hammer just
wanted to show that that was such
such great technique there from artemyev
yeah and the crucial difference between
the knight and the king
as the responsible of stopping magnus's
pawn
is that the knight cannot attack the
and prevent it from moving further
forward at the same time
whereas the king is able to both
attack and stop the white and the the
pond's progress
at the same time so i tamiya they're
really
appreciating what uh the pieces are able
to do
uh and um and and got his
got them coordinated in the right uh in
the right way
yeah well uh yeah
a an end game technique display not from
magnus but from his opponent that hasn't
happened a lot today but right there
vladislav brings this thing to within a
game
um although as you highlighted earlier
hammer magnus doesn't like losing two in
a row
and i do like his position early on here
as black
uh yeah uh but i also want to point out
the the amazing thing about these online
events
uh with magnus and hikaru being the
clearly the top two players
uh in that um in that format
uh they are so expressive
and magnus is still shaking his head
over that last game he did not like
losing there
and um these emotions we're seeing now
from magnus
that's thanks to the camera thanks to
the fact that magnus feels like there's
no one around
and he feels like there's no one
watching but that's not the case at all
though
is it danny no it's not there's a lot of
people watching and as i like to say
when it's online it's there forever
right the internet
um and uh yeah so you gotta you gotta
when you make it when you get a clip of
these guys it really is great though
jokes aside because you see
you know the emotions the fighting
spirit right chess hasn't always been
known for that but uh i think the online
format
and the up close and personal views we
get of the players has kind of brought
that to life so
um all right magnus shaking his head he
needs to move on and focus on this one
artemia has kind of equalized now he was
a little bit worse
what's going on now
um it's a tricky position chances for
both sides
uh what magnus has done well in this
game is that
he he's up on time and time management
has been a problem for him
throughout this match um
but funny humor we've i was gonna say
that
notice that he's am i right do you
remember it correctly like i
remember like i do which is i feel like
every time magnus is lost the next game
he ends up being way up on time
yeah he's got some of that that anger
frustration
manifesting itself into just a
quick play in the next one and frankly
magnus playing quickly trusting his
instincts
that's just as dangerous of an opponent
as magnus questioning his decisions
and using a lot of time
knight d5 i thought would be followed by
bishop to f6
we'll see if magnus goes for that to
challenge the diagonal here
rook to c1 maybe threatens knight c6 so
you gotta watch out no magnus says i'm
good on that i'll play bishop of six
anyway
yeah good job by magnus getting his
bishop
uh to counter uh our tamiya's bishop
and we got a big big tactics here
rook c6 rook c6 bishop b2 knight b2
knight e5
am i right about that for the batcave
yeah i think i was right for once in my
life we found it
brilliant and this is what we were
talking about
magnus magnus's ability to strike back
in uh when in trouble and he finds the
crucial tactic there the knight
attacking both the rogue
and the queen uh and as a result of that
artemyev needed to get his queen out of
the way instead of recapturing magnus's
bishop
which will now be a commanding force
on the board and we said for our tamiya
to win
this for our temiev to uh to
unsettle magnus he needs to win two
games in a row
and vladislav has won quite a few games
today
and he's had chances to win more
but every time magnus loses a game
he strikes back with a vengeance and
that
two-point lead or winning two in a row
for our tamiya has just never been there
because magnus always shuts down um
uh the opponent's chances after a loss
and how he manages to do that i would
love to know well also look at how he's
managing to do it hammer on the clock as
well
like we were saying every time our
champion has won
magnus has i don't want to say one
dominantly but
kind of right he's come back and one
dominantly he's fixed his time
management issues and then you say to
yourself
if you're a magnus fan where is that all
along right play faster magnus right
play angry
and it feels like magnus is playing his
best chess
after losing um and that's not something
he wants to continue to repeat
uh but but as you said it also makes it
really hard for our timber to ever win
two in a row
and uh two knights and a pawn
in exchange for a rook that's a
dominating advantage
and frankly i'm not sure whether
artemyev should resign here or not
from a match strategy standpoint because
if artemyev gets into the one-minute
portion
with just a two-point deficit he's
definitely
capable of making that up so
if he needs to just take his time
uh to to kind of settle his nerves and
and recharge for the next one then
then he should do that that being said
artemis now causing some troubles
uh he managed to capture one of
magnus's uh pawns uh
and it's infamous that two knights
are uh notorious no no
notorious who is notorious b.i.g
uh look at the fork they're bad at
coordinating but
let's show that on the analysis board
real quick
biggie biggie strikes again biggie
biggie biggie oh can't you see
sometimes the fork it hypnotizes me look
at this
knight to c3 you can't take b2 because
of knight to d3 check
that was why the game ended so quickly
everyone artemia was trying to hold with
the rook
but no nice c3 punishes the move king f2
and after the move king e3 you get the
queen
so there you go um i had to give you
credit for that unintentional notorious
big reference by the way tupac lives
that's a whole nother story no too
american for you
no that's fine danny you you already
contributed with some
russian grammar okay so i i got i got a
couple of free cards in your book what
about this line here in this vegeta
cough it's the o'kelly
okay according to uh the eco but who
believes just.com's eco right
let's talk about the structure real
quick because it's especially cough
structure even though a weirdo kelly
with a6
what are your thoughts on on the
position we have here i'm not
so so i'm more interested in the time
than the position because magnus has
been
bad at uh his time management
in the initial hour or so of the
five segment but then he he showed his
true self
in towards the end of the time segment
and i feel like we have a repeat going
on right here
with magnus now suddenly uh
up on time in two games in a row he's
putting pressure on the opponent
he's playing confidently he's playing
quickly he's
posing uh problems um
it's just a different version of magnus
that seems to
uh to to come out
towards the end of each uh time control
right and part of that i think is just
adapting to playing
uh first five-minute chess then adapting
to playing three-minute chess
uh magnus has fully adapted he has the
pace
now for uh for creating maximum damage
in three-minute chess and he's about to
steamroll our tamiya
with his uh bishop and queen and rook
all pointing down uh towards that
black king yeah well said and again it's
just all about
what hammer's highlighting is magnus
kind of finding himself toward the end
of the time controls also finding
himself getting a little angry whenever
he loses it's like
you kind of have to poke the bear to get
the best of the bear
um i was just about to highlight maybe
our tim if should have considered queen
g5 to try to get the ladies off the
board instead of bishop five
but magnus plays f4 and no longer is
there an opportunity to exchange the
queen so
uh this attack could get ugly and look
at the clock it's your
the script is flipped right suddenly
magnus loses he's not happy
and here comes the here comes the
thunder
and artemia must be regretting those two
big chances he had
yeah with the first two games we played
a three minute chess
magnus's time management was all over
the place
he was playing three minute games as if
they were five minute games
and artemiev had two big chances there
to get a win somehow magnus managed to
survive
those games he got a draw out of it and
now
his mind is fully adjusted to this
three-minute section so much so that
he's finding
all the right moves look at that move
i should have gone dr evil pinky finger
cuz
man he's like you can have my bishop
and your mojo and i'll get your baby
look at that
d4 magnus just removing as many pawns in
front of black's king as he possibly can
including not cat recapturing that
bishop
because he loved it he saw that the
bishop wasn't going anywhere
that that piece was going to be a
problem for artemyev
and this has been magnus's most
dominating performance
in this match he just annihilated
artemyev both on the board and on the
clock
that's more of a desperate move although
obviously with kings on different sides
of the board everyone you applaud
attempts to open up lines and create
attacking chances but
at this point it's sort of desperate
because of how bad the position is queen
g3 threatens e5 and rook f6 watch out
here we go he plays it
shake and bake something something's
coming down on the f file it's gonna
hurt
right um yeah even great great play from
magnus there's
no way that king is surviving with the
brook
comfortably finding shelter
deep inside black's position behind the
black pawns
and now also being reinforced by its
buddy
down on the first rank i'm not sure how
uh but these rooks are are going to be
the end
of our time look at that movement d6
with tempo and here comes c5 next just
connecting the passers
so artemia gets desperate by the way
don't blunder it
if you take c7 queen e4 wins because of
the venus flytrap we'll show that on the
analysis board in just a second
uh now let's show it right now what else
we got to do d take c7 queen e4
and bob's your uncle over here never
blunder the venus flytrap kids you heard
here first
okay but of course magnus defends the
knight instead and he's back to
completely winning
yeah because now he's going to remove
the last pawn defending black's king
the king is defenseless artemyev resigns
it's uh that was a a second in a row for
magnus and if he keeps up this pace
he will have left our tamiya in the rear
view mirror
uh well before the one minute time
section
so artemyev now not only having to face
a bad trend
uh in the match he also desperately
needs to start
winning uh because right now the match
is slipping away from him
yeah and this is the biggest whoa g4
this is the biggest lead of the day if
you're just tuning in
uh vladimir bartimi was actually the
first to win today
uh in the beginning of the 5-1 segment
so um and it's been some great chess
from the russian but
but magnus doing what magnus does as the
chat says angry magnus op
right we need like an angry magnus um
hulk oh wait i got one of those he's not
quite angry
but you know i keep something i keep him
anytime i think i'm doing something good
at chess.com i just take a look at this
face staring at me over there in my room
and then i know
i'm not i'll be here all week don't
forget to tip your waitress okay
um back to this position what's going on
i have no idea i i
have especially no idea after that move
from magnus
if i'm out of now i'm exchanging my
bishop for the night
yeah uh oh but then
magnus exchanges there's trickiness
going on right now
oh no he did i thought he might take
with the pawn and just leave this just
what a weird
bleeping setup over here
is this like this makes you wonder if
there was like a mouse slip or something
right when you look at the position you
go how did the pawn get on g4
like yeah but at the same time it's very
creative play from our
yeah and it's clear that he wants to
take
magnus into the forest and and
have a little uh talk with him and then
see if they both
return unscathed um
it's typical play especially against
someone who's shown
poor time management uh to put them in a
situation
where they need to think for themselves
and cannot rely on
um opening moves that they know in
advance
now normally this is the strategy magnus
uses against
everyone else but artemyev is using the
strategy
against magnus himself and then we'll
see if that works out or if that was
uh simply a bad decision on his part
no but also from a practical point of
view i agree with you that artemia
you know he he's losing in the match
right but he refuses to go quietly into
the night he's like well if i'm gonna
lose like you said let's drag magnus
into the deep dark forest where
where no one knows what's going on and
uh and see if see if i can get myself
back in the in the match
as we see though and as you highlighted
magnus is probably the best in the world
at taking people into obscure roads
right and uh he seems to be handling
this g4 approach from our timber just
fine
yeah he's going on the offense huh
yeah a5 what's he going to do you know
he's going to do you're going to play
king b7 he's going to put a rook on a8
you're going to play a4 he's gonna open
the a file
gonna drop the queen like it's hot he's
gonna do dirty things over here
magnus found his mojo there's no
doubting it
right now a4 uh coming in
and if that pawn is captured magnus is
going to bring the knight
to b6 and uh it's going to be a disaster
the e4 play b7 first which was the move
i suggested i like it just a little more
just
now you have all the options you have a4
you have rook a8 coming
you can slow jam it jamie fox style with
rook a8 and knight b6 to prepare
a4 or you can go all in with a4 right
away
but i agree with what you said magnus's
mojo is back
our timmy was in trouble yeah and
artemia now
voluntarily opening up the position
around his own king but he feels like he
has to do it
in order to kind of get his pieces uh
into defensive positions around his own
king and magnus can now win upon
by capturing uh the the white pawn
giving a check
after which magnus is well artemia is
forced to
take with his rook and then magnus can
use his pawn
to attack that vrook and and force it
uh away um and it seems like magnus is
going for this variation
and i think artemia now going to
sacrifice his rook
for magnus's knight which is not what
you want to do when you're down by three
games in this format
uh but maybe it's something you were
forced to do yeah i thought he would do
it too but instead he's going to give up
the pawn with check maybe he says
after you take it i've actually got kind
of a solid defensive setup finally i am
going to bring the other rook to d1
and double on the d file well
moving over to the other side saying
that well
i can try to attack your king as well
however this has caused
uh our tamiya a pawn
oh but look at the time magnus is down
to 30 seconds
and his king is exposed uh this is the
kind of situation
where magnus is going to be very tilted
if he loses this yeah on account
of having such a good position uh
previously so if artemyev can turn this
around that would be a
huge boost for him but also uh
really um stopped that momentum
uh magnus had had going i think f6 just
walked into knight takes e5 hammer
call me crazy just don't call me shirley
i think magnus had knight e1 by the way
maybe crazy move that would have
used those doubled rooks yeah 95 what
what's going on here
i don't think magnus saw that you see
the reaction he looks in it is 19
seconds on the clock
we got scrambled eggs here people buckle
up
yeah which is hilarious
um but yeah he lost control of this game
and now artemia providing the punishment
magnus is down a queen there's rook d1
you have to play brook c1
yeah this this fell apart artemia doing
a magnus carlson
saving something from nothing and if he
wins this game we will still have a
match ladies and gentlemen
our timmy i'm not going quietly into the
night queen
up the board putting pressure on black's
knight magnus will have to defend with
his king
and then the queen infiltrates behind
this coming
uh the pieces kind of a creative defense
there i know the eval bar gets better
for white but i kind of like the awkward
up never mind a5 is falling
i don't like the awkward blockade uh
well i think artemis
is just going to move his way into the
rook's path
by the way queen a5 put a blunder 93
check with a draw which was crazy so
artemyev
sees that and gets the king out of
danger what a brilliant heads up play
with four seconds on the clock
yeah but it's still not over magnus's
brook is still
able to put some uh pressure on white's
king
although there the white queen doing its
job one second
picking up pawns on the other side of
the board
oh my gosh what is going on here is
magnus gonna hold this
five seconds on the clock g5 what a move
check and pawn jack and queen check and
queen yeah but magnus is still fighting
because he has a fight
not easy with only three seconds well
our tenure should take that pawn
yeah and he does so oh
but now the queen comes in a blockading
position and
magnus's knight is too far away to put
pressure on the queen
but magnus coming with the second seat
what just happened what a save
the night the night up against the queen
and the knight you're gonna win he's
gonna hurry seven
oh my god he's got the skewer if you
take
how did he do that 97 yeah
and magnus gets the fork magnus gets the
win
how on earth did he get the win he had a
night against
the queen and the knight wins the game
okay have you seen anything like that
before bring back the analysis board and
bring
back the funk look at this position
fights up a queen
but it was right here king f5 c4
and i think you had to play king e4 you
had to stop
the move c3 but apparently even king f5
was no good
i guess i guess already the position is
closer than you would like but it's
it's really hard for white to deal with
the coming c pawn here
king f5 c4 kudos to magnus for not
giving up but king e4 was the way to
hold the advantage because if check
everyone you go here
and you can't play c3 because the knight
so when when artemyev doesn't play king
e4
all of a sudden the eva bar says no
longer a win in fact it's a draw
but he didn't even get the draw he
didn't even get the draw
you should have played queen takes b2
baby i don't even know but all i know is
magnus just won with a knight versus a
queen
and item nine exists
magnus definitely finding his mojo in
these
last moments of the three three-minute
portion he won
two in a row got himself into trouble
but works his magic and
goes from a losing position to a winning
position
in the time scramble we said it before
the match started the time scramble
is what gave magnus uh the win
against maksudu in the previous matchup
and it's what uh once again
it's what gives him the the advantage in
this matchup with artemyev
he's just so resourceful and
he's so tricky you cannot
even when you're up a queen you cannot
be
confident that you're going to win the
game
and apparently you can't even be
confident i hate those words
coming out of your mouth right there i
hate those words you said even when
you're up a queen you can't be confident
you're going to win the game against
magnus you're so
right it stings i was
dude i'm still just like
seriously i mean i every time i think
i'm about to pass out under these lights
something crazy happens to wake me up
i that that was an incredible game that
was devastating and i think
with it are tamiya imagine how he feels
how do you keep your confidence up
how do you avoid a tilt after losing a
game like that
and in addition that was his third loss
in a row um he's devastated right now
and if he manages to even uh
cut the gap yeah that would be
impressive at this point
because i think magnus now he's got
uh three wins in a row he's confident
he's playing quickly
and he's just throwing everything at
black's king
artemyev is trying to return the favor
with his pawns
but the crucial difference is that when
magnus pushes his pawn
further forward he will attack two
pieces at once he will attack both the
black pawn
on a6 and he will attack the black
knight
forcing there to be some kind of uh
a confrontation uh meaning that magnus
is gonna get rid of his
uh b-pawn uh which will open up
uh all of uh of the files he needs
to put pressure on artemis king
well i yeah i was giving magnus credit
for time management but right
now i think he should just go for it
yeah he's maybe overthinking it a little
bit he is better
but may not matter if you if you reach a
time scramble with a with a full minute
disadvantage
um by the way it's it's possible this
ends up being our last three minute game
everyone
so a shout out to subscribe before we
hit the break uh those of you who enjoy
ads will will love um the latest edition
of capital one
bringing you a new lobby where you can
uh i don't know i'm not gonna do a
capital one thing they don't sponsor the
show
but others will watch me and you hammer
throw down like a couple of tools
in uh in the prime time smackdown all
right 95 was played
it's funny because you take a bunch of
time a minute and 21 seconds to be exact
and you don't even play a good move
with the move 95 and it's funny because
we've seen this happen several times
when magnus loses magnus angry magnus
played better
um now he's not playing
playing too great in this game while
he's trying to go
into an end game and frankly that has
brought him the results
previously in this matchup but he spent
a lot of time uh
thinking uh before he reached this
decision
um i think he's doing just fine and i
think artemiev
i should try to put a speed on because
uh he he doesn't want to get into
another time scramble
against magnus we've seen what magnus is
capable of
in those situations i can't get over the
knight over the queen all right we'll
have to ask them about that game
afterwards
king v8 is a very good move bar temiev
he wants to use the c8 square to put
pressure on the weak and backwards c3
pawn
uh notice that he doesn't doesn't trade
on d4 and help fix
magnus's structure now magnus is trying
to force him to do so
so our tv says no i will not
wow what a creative move by me we bring
the analysis board up real quick
the point everybody is trading queens
here
would create a situation where the g2
pawn is a
serious and backward target magnus plays
this
move g3 says will you trade and fix my
pawns artemis says no
but now g4 if you go back to f4 i will
trade
because i have a pawn that's protected
and no longer backwards sort of
sort of just sneakily fixing the
weaknesses in the structure it's
absolutely
i just that was a brilliant positional
idea there from the world champion
i i completely agree uh but on the other
hand
it cost him a lot of time on the clock
down to eight seconds uh with so many
pieces still
on the board uh artemyev has been having
um a better position several
uh games so far but he's always um
wasted them and let magnus get in at the
very last
moment is this the one where our tamiya
strikes back keeping the match within
striking distance as we go into the one
minute portion
i think the only thing that's clear is
that this is gonna be the last
three minute game there's no way they're
gonna manage to finish within the next
50 seconds as we see on our countdown
clock
on the top and that means artemia
really needs to win this game to have
within
uh three games going into the one minute
portion
agreed town population us um
two seconds for magnus four seconds now
for our champion okay but f2 falls when
you take
there and here comes knight d3 check
with b4 hanging
wow and should magnus now resign to get
another game
in this three minutes
or 15 seconds he's dead lost in the rook
ending magnus is going down here for
sure
but three seconds look at the technique
from our tamiya i'm not even going to
lose the c
pawn yet brings the king up i love it
okay there's a wall of black pawns going
and
moving up towards white's king yeah and
those pawns
are connected that means they're
standing next to each other
and magnus is working his end game magic
hold the phone
uter suddenly says it's equal what's
oh my god magnus why he's around
a second end game in a row and
artemyev is gonna get the abortion
on this game because they're they're
done with the three minutes
the game has been aborted uh they're
down to one minute chess
with magnus winning ma four games in a
row
wasting one brilliant position after
another
i thought with the black pawns being
able to protect
each other i thought that was going to
be it and he had the opportunity
here to move his rook so that he was
attacking both of magnus's pawns
at the same time and that would have
ended the game right there and then
but for the second time in a row the
time trouble
gets magnus's uh opponent
and the resourcefulness magnus shows
and the pressure it
it it illustrates how much pressure
these guys are under uh when they're
under 10 seconds
and repeatedly magnus's opponents makes
mistakes
artemia should have sacrificed his rook
on this white pawn um
and with unclear consequences
uh instead uh his work kind of got
torn between the two white pawns moving
their way
up the board and and magnus secured
himself a new queen
as two pawns uh one square away from
queening
was just too much to handle for uh
unbelievable again i was trying to move
the pieces as you were
talking about the finish there partner
but yeah especially right here was the
win
really hard in time pressure but you had
to go for both
ben magnus again if you're if you're
just joining us where
have you been magnus carlson now of five
games after a tie
at one point our timid was leading it
was a close match
but magnus carlson got angry he rattles
off several victories in a row
and wins two games back-to-back from a
dead lost position
and we're going to have a break here
enjoy wrench versus hammer
prime time smackdown that's me and that
guy right there
that guy and we'll be right back for the
one minute segment here
and the first of a double header on this
speed chess championship thursday
boom all right let's do oh my god stop
playing bad chess hammer
i just i feel like as a countryman to
magnus you should do better
you know i i agree i i would play
something more decent if i could it's
just that i
i have been destroyed through years of
playing this crappy
opening i've just been dreaming i'm so
bad i'm winning now though
i don't even know what to do with you
it's so bad
and you're frustrating me right now you
are frustrating me
okay position is still horrible
i don't even care oh i shouldn't have
done that
almost pre-moved rook takes f2 would
have been somewhat
unfortunate a decent amount of pawns i
guess
like this isn't the worst amount of
pawns that anyone's ever had
no it's not but look how many pawns you
have now
yeah crap your style is so
irritating i'm pretty much
meaning it's a horrible style that you
have well thank you
these openings that you play you want to
know my secret
i thought i was bad at openings god
all right damn put yourself together
get the bishop pair and go into an end
game every single game 100
success right always imagine dan that
they're
that they're at home in their underwear
and it makes you feel better
always imagine that makes me feel better
don't be embarrassed there's a little
pep talk
in myself whenever i feel like i'm
embarrassing myself on camera i just go
like remember
people are at home naked cheeto marks on
their bare chest
watching you and judging you that's you
know don't be embarrassed
that's what i tell myself i no longer
wish for my kids
to have your brain oh no i'm kidding
but this is getting abusive all right
here we go all right i'm gonna be black
against the stupid g3 crap
you know what's coming you literally
know my first five
i know what's coming do something about
it
i hate you i'm gonna do what levy did
[Music]
i'm gonna play this sort of like crazy
looking sort of uh
crazy looking kind of
you know whatever this is
okay step one acquire bishop pair
step one completely what's step two
like still have a bad position even with
the bishop bear
preferably not getting checkmated
because that's working out for you yeah
not right now
this is this is no no i'm not
i am not doing this with you i'm up a
piece and you're gonna lose this
freaking game
or i'm gonna lose my proverbial bleep
okay
if i lose this game it's not because i'm
a piece down it's because i don't have
the bishop pair
that's the problem yeah that's how much
faith i have in the bishops
you have a problem bro the bishop hera
is not the only thing in life
okay i was okay it was okay it really
really gave me a scare
really gave me a scare meaning you
really gave me a scare hammer
and i tried like it
[Music]
uh can you make that move i am not
really sure
kind of scared
very scared be very scared
can i i'm not gonna lose to danny on
camera
please no just my dude worst things have
happened to better people
okay i'm not sure that's entirely true
oh wait i'm good i just do something bad
fine
no i lost connection no way
no way no way you lose
is horrible i lost my connection this is
outrageous this is rigged are you
kidding me
as much as the next chess player but
that's where the smackdowns are
happening
oh come on it just happened to be during
a game
against the chief chess officer whatever
my connection just randomly disappeared
when i was about to go right rematch
your connection's fine that was an
excuse i just flagged you like a dirty
dirty dog
how'd that how did that loss feel right
there in that prime time i don't want to
talk about it
how did that like you were you were in a
lost rook ending and you got flagged
ruthlessly i mean you want to talk about
that
all right let's go to the predictions
hammer's silent i uh
i know that the smarter chess stats say
that magnus is gonna be
four games better and one plus one twist
ending
what if artemia ends up being four games
better oh crap i realize he's still
gonna lose
yeah uh it's been uh
are you still just frustrated with
yourself
um yeah
well um jokes aside this has been an
amazing day and we know that the
current scoreboard is five games to the
advantage of magnus carlsen
but it's been um it's been a super close
match on the board in a lot of ways
and the world champion showing why he is
uh why he is such and uh
always seems to to have the moves and
the critical moments including winning
knight versus queen it's hard to talk
about anything else besides that game
right now and then the rook ending
coming up
good yeah magnus winning two losing
games in a row
that puts that kind of puts everything
to rest
i don't think artemis can can come back
from that
had he got the wins the points he
deserved the score would have been eight
to seven
everything to play for instead now here
he is
down five points uh
it just shows how how close this match
was
and frankly how much the the current
result
is is a complete lie uh compared to what
we have witnessed
because it's been a closely contested
match
with just mad magnus pulling out his
magnus magic uh at the end
uh which has just catapulted his number
of points
into a number that he
uh he he doesn't believe
vladislav doesn't believe uh artemia
just shaking his head
and i'm still stunned that magnus got
away with that
well the 1-1 section should be starting
right now
any second it is going to kick off and
here we go a half an hour left for
artemyev to uh to make his move
if a historical comeback is in store for
today
but you know you said it all you know
the the scoreboard doesn't totally
reflect
what an exciting uh day we've had how
close the games have been and the five
one portion
the fact that we felt our tim you've
might have been the better player
overall
you know um but but again that's why
he's
as you said magical magnus and now we've
got some weirdness coming with the
double fee and kettles for both sides
sign me up this is going to be an
awkward party
well it's very likely that all those
bishops are going to be pointing at
each other and frankly uh they might
just all get exchanged off
but it's artemia with a better position
because of
magnus having his one knight out on the
edge of the board
that gives white a slight edge
yeah agreed it's a double hanging pawn
position
at some point the tension's going to
break you got to give white i think the
teeny
edge i think having released the uh the
eye of the tiger on g2 first
and now yeah now oh he took with the
pawn i wonder if there was an awkward
way to take advantage of the knight but
no
and magnus is going to be targeting
these white pawns
uh artemyev is going to claim that these
pawns give him
a very nice central control and he's
going to try to get his knights
in there artemia now going to move this
knight up to b5
trying to get it into uh d6 getting
it right in there uh annoying magnus to
the maxim
speaking of annoying that move knight
before knight c6 got him annoyed artemia
because he doesn't
doesn't get much out of it and if the
knights are traded everyone one thing to
recognize with hanging pawns is that as
pieces come off the board
the pawns become easier to gang up on
all of a sudden it's sort of turning
around
and although okay what are we doing here
yeah i'm surprised artemia went for the
exchanges he's down
five points it felt as though he he
needed to
to keep more pieces on the board we'll
see if he can get a win here
in the time scramble uh in the end game
but frankly don't count on it because
magnus in the end game
he doesn't care if he's down a queen
he's just gonna win them
that has been the crucial difference uh
so far
in this matchup
actually gets away with winning a pawn
on the side of the board
are tamiya pawn up in this end game
uh but when he didn't manage to win with
a queen up
i can't get excited about him being a
pawn up
it's it's hard it's not going to be the
punch line for the day because it's
something we've rarely seen
uh in an event featuring you know two
super grand masters even if it is blitz
so
our timmy oh but there magnus makes a
huge mistake
allowing the knight to get the double
attack on the
rook and on the pawn it means our temiev
snatches the pawn and magnus
uh two pawns down that i do not believe
he's going to be able to save
and artemia strikes back is it going to
be too late
he's down five points in the matchup
[Music]
uh
got weird weird threats coming here with
rookie three
even knight f4 i mean the pawn pawn is
hanging
yeah and magnus is familiar with the
format there's no way he's gonna resign
when he's up five in the match here it's
all about surviving as long as possible
to keep that match clock ticking yep
26 minutes left remember that is
something that
especially pays dividend in a close
match but even just as an insurance
policy you're up by
five make your opponent earn it right
and um
when you win games down queens hammer
it's hard to ever
justify resigning so
uh but there are tamiya before the
checkmate he takes the first game
of this one minute portion the lead is
down to four
and artemyev for the third or fourth
time in this match
gets the opportunity to inflict two
losses in a row for magnus
so far he has not succeeded in doing
that
uh which i think is the the crucial
thing you need to do
to unsettle magnus to get magnus in a
poor psychological state
um can artemyev
get the second win or will magnus do
what he's made a habit out of
uh which is play somehow
much better after having lost yep
it's been the story of the day our
teammate has been close it seemed at
times to getting that
magical second victory will anyone in
the scc be able to put magnus on a tilt
um we'll we'll find out of course i
don't i don't know that it's going to
happen today it would take a miracle for
our tim you have to come all the way
back
but it starts with one game yeah it
starts with one game and then there's
another game
and artemyev gets his knight in an
excellent position
putting pressure on white's bishop which
means that magnus cannot
castle the big question is what's next i
think artemis should just move his
bishop out
to d7 and he does do that magnus's brook
is out of squares magnus cannot castle
the rook is is is in trouble every piece
is in trouble
it looks as though our tamiya is going
to take a second game
in a row here magnus brook has been
trapped
the rook has nowhere to go uh but on the
other hand
magnus just got his bishops in good
positions
i was gonna say everything you said was
true is what i would have commented too
but then also the exchange stack happens
and magnus's pawns are running wild
what in the world
his resourcefulness is just it's
incredible
it's it's incredible seriously and
because that was such a such a
a bad position for white and certainly
artemia blundered
but but neither you or i can exactly say
where
and just like that and
then i i have no idea what's going
on yeah i think bishop c7 was actually
better than bishop d6 than what magnus
played but
either way he's he's back in the game
after what seemed like a dead loss
and why is magnus allowing the knight to
be exchanged for the bishop
i'm not sure it feels to me like
artemyev in this opposite colored bishop
end game
should be able uh to hold on for a draw
um but magnus coming with his rook
magnus has a pawn
one square away from becoming a new
queen artemiev is trying to eliminate
all the pawns on the other side of the
board um
but now magnus will get his king
involved
and there's not really much artemiev can
do with it
artemis king is unable to participate in
play
uh because of the white rook pointing
down
making sure that artemium cannot get his
king next to
the white pawn yeah and
what surprises me is that magnus is
moving his king
in the wrong direction now you got to
watch out that was actually a really
nice trick from our champion it might
force rookie five
because the point is if the bishop moves
everyone yeah d7 falls and if he didn't
h5 was a threat so
nice defense there from artemia of
forcing the rook exchange
now he should for sure you should for
sure hold this
and uh okay well hammer it's not two
wins in a row
but it's two decent results in a row a
win and a draw
so yeah but he had the upper hand and
let it slip and even though he's happy
to have avoided a loss
um i just can't help the feeling that
um artemiev really needed that
two in a row uh to get momentum and
look at magnus's reaction there magnus's
reaction was not one of
i wasted an opportunity to win magnus's
reaction was
i got away with that right and that
three and a half more minutes off the
game clock
match clock right no i'm with you i'm
just saying you know
but there's a will there's a way and
right now with 21 minutes left
artemyev uh another victory here would
would keep it close so the point is
point is you just i don't know for sure
if i'm right it's been a long day
already but
i think magnus has always won after
losing
and that was the first time artemia drew
the next game so that's all i was saying
a couple decent results in a row
yeah he i think he desperately needs to
win this one
yeah no i agree it's it's time to win
or and now he knows it as well because
he's going aggressive
with his pawns pushing magnus's queen
back
and now putting his rook on the same
file as magnus's queen
the queen gets away how are you going to
break down
magnus's position here i think part of
the problem here for artemyev
is that it's going to be a 90 move game
magnus is just going to block off
everything
and then the match clock is going to run
its course
in addition to it being almost
impossible to defeat magnus
in in such a a technical position
meaning that
uh there's like uh a very limited of
pieces
left um it's just also the fact that
magnus can keep the game
going for quite some time exploiting the
fact that the match clock keeps running
yep and i'm liking the way magnus
handled the pressure to be honest
regardless of
all the other difficulties we've said
artemia faces i think that
it's roughly equal in terms of
in terms of the queen side play and the
two-on-one
being the long-term advantage i feel
like is uh
is good for magnus although this moved
by d5 that's that's kind of irritating
because if you take
your knight is being pushed to a less
than ideal square
um and magnus is spending a lot of time
figuring it out
uh in the end deciding to retreat
um and both players now uh under 20
seconds
so here comes the two on one as we said
uh but now artemia has successfully
blockaded
are you gonna put it on c6 go for a five
minutes gonna move it forward
do it but there's knight d7 you gotta
watch upward no queen d3
what a weird move
well magnus's queen attacking both
white's rook and white's
knight grabbing a pawn in the process
so magnus won quite a lot of material
there but
gets forced back afterwards and now
artemyev
despite being a pawn down he has this
pawn running up the board trying to
become a new queen
magnus up upon um seems to have enough
resources in the position to stop
that white pawn from moving forward
but magnus plays
white figured this out somehow i mean
that what a weird position
this is one that as a chess fan i feel
robbed i wish they i wish the players
had more time to play that position a
little more accurately because the email
bar was nutty
and i think um i don't think the best
chess was played but hey what did we
call for we said our timmy has to win
another game in a row
and it might yeah but he's not won this
one yet
magnus uh as always being very
resourceful creating trouble for
white trying to can't happen again oh my
gosh
trying to get he's losing in
what i have no idea what's going on
hey f2 shame on you
what is going on the eval bar
is is still in magnus's uh in artemia's
favor
he barely knows this one pawn he has
moving forward that pawn needs to become
a new queen if he's to have any chance
of winning this game
magnus right now just giving checks to
the white king repeatedly
and the white king is struggling to know
and now he blundered the pawn which
means magnus
now will go for the win uh our temmie of
just having three seconds
left this is anyone's game the knight
and queen are
the best duo in the business when it
comes to mating nets against the king
and so i i would rather have the queen
and knight here than the queen of rook
this is i agree the night is so tricky
and white's king is poorly defended
uh so it's much easier for uh magnus to
hide his king than it is for artemia
yeah and just to prove the point if if
magnus wanted to draw he could offer the
queen straight now he might take it with
perpetual here indeed he does but still
that was
it was a game that don't kid yourself
magnus was the one hoping to win it
toward the end
and again he prevents artemia from
getting that
that so desired second win in a row
right it's
it's been a win for artemia and bullet
everyone two draws
but not another victory that artemia
needs now with only 16 minutes left
and in both draws it was artemyev who
was closest to the wind
and also in the last two games of the
five three minute portion
it was artemiev who had very promising
winning positions
which he wasted in time trouble and
ended up losing
consider uh danny if all of those four
games
had gone in artemis favor instead he
would be the clear leader
of this match but now instead
he he keeps you know having to chase a
win trying to get back uh
as a result of of not exploiting the
chances he's
been getting yep dog chasing his tail
going in circles not getting anywhere
that's how our tamiya feels by the way
we have more than 10 000 live viewers on
youtube
that might be a record for our growing
youtube channel we've been live
streaming on twitch
a little bit longer over the last 10
plus years here on chess.com so that's
cool
and uh still got 24 000 of you almost on
twitch so thanks for being here remember
right after this match we'll have
interviews
with the world champion magnus carlson
vladislav artemyev
and then we buckle up for nakamura fedo
sev
uh it's that's gonna be a fun one like
hammer keep saying it's quite a day
today what a day to be alive
huh take that 20 20.
two speed chess uh quarterfinals on the
same day
and also it being hikaru and
magnus uh it's just perfect
uh i think gtx h3 was the move there
and for some reason artemia took
magnus's bluff
yeah i think he takes winning for black
yeah
well based on the evaluation bar that
was definitely the case
but neither player seemed to believe the
attack black had going on
well now magnus is back in the driver's
seat with a dominant knight on e5
and that knight was just shutting down
the studio in regards to any kind of
action over there
on the king side so interesting sort of
uh
central blockade there from carlson
artemia misses his opportunity
oh man and with with only 14 minutes
left if this one ends up being a dub for
the world champion
i think we'll almost have to call it our
timmy you've got to hold
yeah no doubt and magnus's pawns on the
queen side are
terrifying he has two pawns that protect
each other
as they move forward and these pawns are
going to become
queens our tamiya resigns magnus has
a five point lead and look at the relief
in magnus's face
that's how close this match has been
magnus is thrilled to get that
five-point lead
which normally would be more than enough
to feel
extremely confident that you're gonna
win this
but but magnus is like oh wow this has
been a challenge
i'm so happy uh i'm about to
to win this no i agree that face says it
all if any of you were late this has
been a
super close match all day our timmy have
led and felt like the better player in
the first segment
magnus seems to have found it where it
matters the most but that that relief
you just saw
was magnus kind of feeling like all
right five games lead 12 minutes left i
think
i'm gonna get this and he has a ton of
respect
for his opponent in vladislav artemyev
and and magnus now uh he's gonna get
more points
uh but even if he didn't get more points
he would be able to run the clock
uh as it stands on these last five games
feels so close you're right like this
feels like a match that just a second
ago could have gone either way
yeah artemia actually snatches a pawn in
the center
but magnus with the two bishops putting
pressure on white's position
is saying that even though i'm down a
pawn
i'm gonna create some trouble and this
guy on the side of the board
that uh danny just highlighted that
is uh instrumental to magnus's plan
because he's gonna push this guy forward
and um
white's king is gonna feel uncomfortable
at the at the pressure eleven by the way
uh speaking of uncomfortable look at the
clock
yeah no magnus is uh in in the in the
mode now
yeah he's in his killer mode and i think
he's about to sacrifice something
on white's king position to really open
up the board and create trouble
i wonder if he could have even taken h2
with g3 and then h3 that would have been
a
way to sacrifice something it doesn't um
not necessary but oh wow and now
artemia he's got an attack going on as
well
both players attacking the computer
massively favors white and then
changes his mind and massively and now
uh
saying it's about equal
and now favors white again incredible
stuff
there's an open file for a white rook to
point down towards
this black king i think that's going to
be the deciding factor
when white gets the rook involved
there's just
no saving it and artemia is going to
finish with a nice
rook sacrifice rook b8 rook
oh he had it rook b8 and then rook over
and queen in i think was also made but
this
should work i think it should be good
enough
we've said that a couple of times today
danny oh yeah we've said that
what we mean it magnificent
exchange and then the checkmate our
tamiya gets another one back
and um i mean i guess
technically he can still get a comeback
four games in 10 minutes
but he's gonna have to play faster he's
gonna spend need to spend
no time on his clock while putting the
squeeze on magnus
yeah it's not it's not going to be easy
it it's
possible if not um improbable right i
mean
the the 10 minute time is just it goes
by faster than you think right
especially with increment you feel like
no four games in 10 minutes like that's
doable but
you know um really really hard although
again you watched the ferruccia fedo
save match that i comment
commentated on with the it was
incredible that was incredible
and it was it was four minutes and a
two-game deficit but it took
it took not just winning but then
starting the last game as time expired
and that's the rules of the match format
if a game starts it does count and then
winning that so even there
yes it happened but it barely got in
under the wire so
um yeah
and uh opposite side castling
is definitely what artemyev likes to see
when he's chasing uh a lead
uh the problem uh being that magnus is
creating some trouble for black's king
i guess that's just the cost of doing
business artemiev is happy to
get his pawns involved he's to be
putting pressure
on magnus's bishop and i think there's a
very real possibility now
that artemyev is going to win this game
i think
he has a great attack going on towards
magnus's king yeah magnus taking his
time
to figure it out because a4 is a problem
if you play c3 everyone the point is a4
comes with tempo
and then a3 to follow would undermine
the b pawn between c3 so that's why
magnus doesn't play c3
but now he may not have any choice right
i mean a4 is coming like it or not
well matt you gotta make a4 himself i
thought
because now oh this is tricky magnus is
trying to shut down
everything if art artemia
plays b4 then a4 from magnus and vice
versa
uh artemiev needs to try and open up the
situation
get rid of those pawns so that he can
get in towards white's king and the way
he does it
is very instructive or tamiya having
give
given up two pawns is still the favorite
to win this game
because of white's exposed king
and now it's just a matter of getting
more pieces involved in the attack
maybe knight h5 is a move brook creates
a move
yeah i would go with the rook and i
wouldn't spend this much time
yeah our tennis needs to keep the the
time situation within reach
yeah rook c3 grace if you take 94 was a
fork town
and now queen takes the pawn yes and
then you take very nice
he gets back the two pawns he sacrificed
initially
and now still has an attack going while
white's bishop on b1 is a
horrible nobody just hung his knight
just straight up
yeah he misses it and magnus missed it
bishop c won
is taking the bishop and now magnus sees
the knight in the center
uh once again an end game both players
very low on time
but artemia about to bring his king into
the fold
i think black's king is going to decide
this end game
or tim yam strikes twice in a row for
the first don't
don't i don't wanna i'm like hold your
horses over there partner given what
we've seen i'm not gonna call a victory
at this point i mean our tim you've
hung his knight magnus missed it our
timmy of hangs is i mean magnus hangs
his bishop instead
oh yeah i'm calling it danny artery is
gonna win two in a row
but i think it's too late for him i
think
okay now okay now he can play kinky five
in here so yeah yeah but now there's
pressure against these black puns
i didn't really like that trade from
yeah but he's got he's six he should be
okay right yeah you take advantage of
the pin
should still win yeah okay good play
never magnus is gonna play this
trust a russian in an end game
instructor russian and end games that
sounds like uh
well like the next netflix series
but despite all of this excitement
despite artemyev about to win his second
game in a row
he's not able to catch up because the
match clock is running out
he needs to have three wins uh
in in the rest of this match and i'm not
sure
five minutes is enough to get those
three wins
he's not only gonna have to play quickly
and
amazingly in the next couple of games he
also needs to stop
using his own clock the only way
artemium can mount to come back here
is if he in his next game plays as if
it's like a 10 second game right he
needs to
avoid spending his own time because at
this point spending his own time
will run down the match clock
yep and i think magnus i should like he
said too little
too late not enough time um but uh
that was still a very a very impressive
victory and carlson just ensuring
ensuring that every second will go off
the clock shows you how much respect he
has for his opponent doesn't want to
allow
any opening cynical but it's so great
this is what this
format is all about let the clock run
out
you lost control of the match your
opponent has won two games in a row
you need to stall to uh
to get rid of that momentum well magnus
laughing a little bit kind of like sorry
man but hey this is this is them is the
rules
them's the rules he's like don't hate
the player hate the game that was that
magnus laugh right there
let's let's clip it magnus don't hate
the player hate the game man
where is the next game are 10 i don't
know both sides trying to rematch
i'm sure they're not delaying but it
happens sometimes um
yeah wow a great game from artemyev as
you said not going to be enough time
and uh i think the clock was
425 so i'm guessing we'll add some total
time back on the clock just for good
measure
um i'm not sure exactly what's going on
we'll check in with them
but this break is uh definitely in
magnus's favor
uh because he gets some time to calm
himself down
and um and
uh and on the heels of those two defeats
in a row you can see
it's taken a toll on magnus he really
doesn't like
uh losing two in a row he lost momentum
in the match
and now artemyev needs to play super
quickly
uh to have any chance of uh of getting
back his uh
three-point deficit
yeah three points
and uh it get he gets a good start here
artemyev
um uh with his pieces developed
magnus opting for not castling
and allowing an attack to be mounted
on the black king very dangerous play
here from magnus
um with the king still in the center
with an
artemia desperate to get a win
can he do three in a row against the
world champion
that would be the task right
unfortunately with time although
let's not let's not forget everyone of
the format right every game is actually
worth
probably a couple hundred bucks at this
point because the prize money
while 3 000 goes to the winner the
remaining 3000 is split by win
percentage
and so uh everyone goes home with cash
and even if you lose there's an
opportunity to still fight down the
stretch so
or reason to fight down the stretch and
artemyev
going for it with a peace sacrifice the
computer hates it
but black's king has been um
undressed the the the pawns no longer
there to defend the king
fortunately for magnus uh there's so
many black pieces around
and he's just gonna play his pieces uh
to kind of
do the job that the pawns are no longer
there to do
uh trying to protect his majesty
i like the threat of f5 here i like the
sack right whether it works or not like
you said artemia's going for it
in our final couple games here we're
adjusting the clock to make sure that
the time is accurate based on how much
was delayed
don't you stress chad don't worry i'll
feed you baby birds
the uh the clock what had time added
back to it but it now reflects the
accurate time remaining
um
and uh artemia striking
with the bishop he magnus couldn't
capture the white bishop because of the
the rook in trouble uh in the corner of
the board
but magnus is resourceful and has nine
oh my gosh
itself let's bring up the analysis board
as the next game start just a show
because what what a turnaround right
bishop takes f7
right winning tactic for white
you know deflect the queen not so fast
magnet says winning tactic for black you
take my queen i take yours with check
and then regain the bishop um
yeah and with that win there's no doubt
who's gonna win this match
magnus carlsen is victorious he's going
to go
into the semi-finals against maxim
barcelo
lagrave um but
uh this has been such a close match
yeah and uh with better um
nerves and better decision making in in
time scrambles
uh our tamiya could have won this uh
match in in a blowout it's been
incredible to watch
how magnus manages to create trouble for
his opponent
and and get so many points in these time
scrambles
even situations where he's losing he
manages to turn it around
and even get a win uh so um
in the end magnus wins as we are
accustomed to
but um a big fight from the
the russian player
yep
well uh this will be the final game
uh though the result of course does
count
and uh it will affect prize money and
all that stuff but we're gonna have
interviews with the players we'll get
magnus's thoughts
on how the match went facing maxine
bache the grav in the next round
and maybe some other things along with
it so don't go anywhere and of course uh
hammer and i will do a quick preview of
nakamura fedocea before my partner
steps out and makes way for a new one
a new partner in robert hess um
i'm a little promiscuous today i'm
swapping partners around
and uh hammer i know you'll be sitting
there watching
hanging out with us in spirit
uh anyway what a day this has been this
has been quite the match this has been a
lot closer than the final scoreboard
says it felt like we could have almost
had overtime today your right hammer
might have even been a victory for our
champion if he could have converted some
of those time scrambles
but i i guess it's no accident because
this is the same thing we were talking
about in magnus's last match
he somehow ends up landing on his feet
he somehow has the margins in his favor
and uh artemia they're getting a double
attack on
white's bishop and on the white king or
tamiya gets the extra piece
it looks as though he's going to win
this last
game of the day but it's only going to
be a consolation prize
uh because the final score if artemium
now
brings home the bacon uh it is going to
be
13 for magnus and 10 for artemyev
so not the uh definitely not the
prediction that smarter chess went for
and you know we we like to make fun of
the of the module it's it's right a lot
of the time
but i do not like that decision from our
tamiya
he gives and that just gave the draw
right back yeah he gives up the knight
he had extra and now magnus is just
trying to get rid of as many pawns as he
can
uh secure
yeah and magnus able to now put up a
blockade on the dark squares
the disadvantage of having only one
bishop the reason you need to have the
bishop pair
is because they need to work together
one controlling the light squares
the other controlling the dark squares
here magnus
has been able to put his uh king his
knight and his pawn on the dark squares
there's no way for artemyev to make
progress
and this last game was pretty much
descriptive
of this entire day artemia playing great
chess
getting advantages but magnus staying in
there
showing his fighting spirit and and
managing to
to get points in a lot of difficult
situations
agreed agreed agreed and it wouldn't be
a show with john love the camera if we
didn't end with a reference to why you
need the bishop here
okay hopefully you enjoyed that just
like all of our subscribers will enjoy
the last of our prime time smackdown
between
me and hammered that took place a couple
weeks ago a lot of fun
hopefully everyone is enjoying that
content don't go anywhere when we return
we have interviews with magnus carlson
vladislav artemyev
before previewing nakamura fedo sayo
we'll be right back
[Music]
you can't see what's going on on my
screen that was the
server intervened on your behalf oh wait
are you are you literally disconnected
okay cool
connection for one second but in one
minute chess that's all it takes
oh my god it didn't matter hammer i was
crushing you up two pawns in a rook end
game and flagging you like in a like
like a i don't even know what i want to
say because it's not appropriate
i don't want to hear it you know what
you want to say but you've decided
it's not appropriate i think it's like
wait am i going to get my own night trap
yeah well ghana or
already damn how did that happen how did
that happen
all right my moves are just comebacks
are possible
miracles happen
come on come on let's do this
there you go there you go make bad moves
hammer that's what i love about you
always up to make a bad move for a
friend
oh you are you are just an adorable
little bad move maker
by the way how's that rook feel over
there it's
fine don't worry about it does that rook
feel okay
how's that it's fine don't worry about
it oh
you did get out of it somehow i'm
actually really irritated about that
uh come on this is so awkward for you
you see everything is fine crap
everything was not fine for you and you
know it i wasn't even concerned for a
second
oh man i'm going one time again how did
that happen
i hope
honestly somewhat uncomfortable
situation going down
what are you doing stop attacking things
[Music]
what no way you just did that oh my god
you're such a dirty player
i love it no
no i'm in check oh it was a check with
the fish
i almost i almost rocked your world like
the
little norwegian country girl you truly
are honestly i'm surprised the server
didn't come in
and take my connection again everybody
blames chess.com servers when they lose
to me
it's part of life you know but
you know i i thought you were better
than that i guess i was wrong
and welcome back everyone we are now
joined by our players world champion
magnus carlson and vladislav artemyev
guys first of all thank you both this
was uh
quite the show today a super exciting
match and vlad
we'll start with you i i know the
scoreboard reflects
a four-point loss it felt a lot closer
than that felt like you were playing
super well throughout the day what can
you say about those time scrambles where
magnus just
continues to create resourceful problems
and how he how he
how he stole some victories there from
you in those uh especially in that three
minute portion
with the knight versus queen ending
uh yes i think that much was
very interesting and uncompromising but
also i can say that
i i have big problems when i have last
seconds and
probably i missed some great chances
but okay it fight and i
it's only my problems so
thank you magnus and congratulations
uh yes maybe
i lost crazy two games when i was
queen against rook and tonight
it was very terrible for me and
more crazy i think it was rooks
and game with two pawns for me
yes i i was very disappointed after this
and
it's really difficult play after such
crazy games but i try
to make some fight and okay
no normal match not good result but my
opponent was very strong so okay
um magnus back back over to you then uh
one of the things that hammer and i
observed today is that
every time you lost a game it felt like
it felt like the beast came out
people were saying in chat like angry
magnus is overpowering and was there
something for you that if you had a
tough game
it kind of riled you one of the things
we noticed is you played faster the next
game and you tend to
to really find your form is is that
something you can talk about as far as
when you lose a game what it kind of you
know woke you up a little bit
and made you feel even more focused for
the next game
uh i have to say that uh
the match overall was uh was tough
um almost every game was was tough like
i think over the course of the match
there was one game which i
uh which i won without any any hiccups
so if you're talking about angry that
was
sort of my constant constant mood
throughout the match like every game was
was long it felt like i was outplayed in
almost every game
and so it was just uh it was just a
massive struggle uh
and i played i played vlad before so
i knew that he uh he's very strong and i
knew that
the match was never going to um to be uh
be easy but still like when you're when
you're there i think
we both really really felt the the
tension
very much in in that sense it was a very
interesting and
and um yeah very open match as well
um magnus um what is
the ability you have to turn around
uh difficult situations
i don't know keep making moves
and uh sometimes i escape sometimes
uh sometimes i don't um
[Music]
i mean i've had experience in this
format as well like
i played um overall
in this format so many games with
grishok for instance and
yeah he just outplays me every time
a bit like vlad does so i have a lot of
experience in
trying to fight back and be as resource
resourceful as possible
i think it's
just knowing when to start playing fast
helps
and also to be on constant lookout for
for tricks i don't think there's any
you said you have a lot of experience in
this format magnus and and talking about
that toward the end of this match here
you were definitely using the time to
your advantage right and was that just
kind of a
you know the show of respect you have
for vladislav you wanted to make sure
that with the lead you protected it
kind of letting the time kick off the
clock there in the final games of the
bullet portion
no as i said before even though i was
leading
by quite a big score um
there was no moment in the match where i
felt like
i'm taking over he's starting to um
to crack it always felt like the games
were
um very balanced in the sense that we
both
both had chances and never felt like i
was sort of
breaking away and in that sense i
thought i
have to be um i have to be careful
because i didn't
really feel that i could control the
match very much and
in that sense it was good just to to
to let it run out i was very mindful of
that
who knows if the match had gone on for
another
another half an hour it could could have
ended differently
yep makes sense magnus uh with the the
jokes aside we were saying about how we
observed you getting frustrated
being angry hammer and i talked a lot
about how great this year has been with
so many awesome online events you have
the magnus carlson tour that you've been
doing at chess24 which is incredible
we have these events where we get to see
the players on camera talk a little bit
if you will
as the ambassador for the game that you
are what you feel online chess has done
right giving
it sometimes feel like fans feel a
little more intimately close to you guys
in online events right because we get
the camera we get to see magnus at home
kind of reacting emotionally
in ways that you don't always over the
board so if you would say how you feel
about the online events here and how
great it's been for fans to be able to
connect with players
on camera like this yeah i think you hit
on on the
the biggest point right there that you
i mean somewhat paradoxically you feel
you feel like you get more raw emotions
when people
are on um are online than they are
irl so um yeah that's that's certainly
certainly the case and for us as well
it's it's it's good to play from
uh from home and um
yeah it's just uh it's just a great
thing for
for chess i think that there are now
very serious online online events that
people
people can can watch
for sure well and we appreciate that and
all the events that are running online
both
with chess24 and just.com and we think
they've been amazing so
vladislav i want to just say again i
know that the score obviously
not what you wanted to win the match but
what do you take away from something
like this as far as what you learn
despite you know you played the world
champion that's one thing you learned
and he plays a lot of good moves but
what do you learn as far as things you
can take away and improve upon
in future speed chess matches
uh yes before the match i have
opinion that magnus is favorite
of course but i'm also not bad player
so i wanted to
found my chances and of course i
not can say that i am happy now because
uh when when you lost it's
always bad but still
i not can say that i was very bad
i was normal i think maybe
i can play better i i think that
i can play a little better yes but
it's a difficult walk
one such long match against magnus so
i must walk more and
i will wait others
great events and hope that uh iridone
in speeches championship in next year
thank you yeah well thank you and best
of luck
at the russian super final we know
you'll be traveling to that and you've
had
you had an incredible year you're
someone who qualified in the speeches
grand prix you've been one of the most
consistent
albeit dominant forces in the in the
world of online chess so
uh you earned it and great match today
uh magnus last question for you
you've got mvl in the semifinals
thoughts on thoughts on that match-up
and
uh how do you think you pair off again
uh face-off against the fresh the
frenchman
uh i think he's a very different uh
different player than vladislav
in this um format like
maxim is a lot more reliant on
on tactics and and and speed so it's
certainly going to be very
very different very very different
experience
yeah well best of luck in the next round
magnus we'll see you next weekend um
vladislav good luck at the russian super
final and uh thank you both for your
time
uh thanks a lot see you in next time